[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to today's
special coverage of the january 6
select public hearings we have a special
hearing for you today it was announced
yesterday um very very very abruptly
that there would be a
hearing day we didn't we didn't think
that we would actually have one of these
hearings until sometime in july
something has happened with evidence and
this witness that we will
talk rc talk today a cassidy hutchinson
an aide to the former white house chief
of staff mark meadows she would be with
mark meadows
in most of his duties right next to him
taking notes
using
um the calendar to schedule meetings
with him and
for some reason we see new evidence uh
as one of the reasons why the january 6
select committee has has chosen to give
us this urgent hearing that we were
going to see today
a lot of speculation about that some
have said that
cassidy hutchinson has changed attorney
switched attorneys also has testified
again to the select committee within the
last 10 days some of the reports coming
out about that i'm also
also that there is threats on her um and
we're going to get to the bottom of this
with our commentary today so welcome my
name is tony michaels i am the host here
of today's especial hearing of the
january 6th select committee uh today is
is going to be a bombshell i think i
want to bring in my first guest to talk
about um switching lawyers and why this
all seems
important or why it should seem
important let me go to michael popock
one of the hosts of legal af
michael how are you today i'm doing
great tony how are you doing oh i'm
doing fantastic tell me what you think
about um this situation where she has
switched attorneys do you think that
makes a big difference where she
switched attorneys in the last few weeks
um and then
it seems like it seems like she has
testified within the last 10 days gave
an additional testimony on whatever new
evidence that they found what's your
what's your thoughts on it well let me
frame it for people that are just
joining
and then we'll get to the change in
council which i do believe
um had an impact on her now cooperating
closely with the gen 6 committee um
cassidy hutchinson is the proverbial fly
on the wall that we'd all like to be on
the west wing she was not only mark
meadows last
executive assistant she was the chief of
staff meaning she was in every room that
he was in she arranged every meeting and
call that he was involved with
and particularly reporting has come out
that in the last 30 days including in
the last week she's given testimony
about the following events that she
watched mark meadows her boss burn
papers
which are
papers that needed to be preserved for
record keeping in the national archives
in his fireplace in his office and
especially after he met
with
a a congressman to discuss
representative scott representative
scott perry to discuss
jeff clark being elevated to attorney
general she also was involved with
arranging the trip and accompanying
meadows in december to georgia meadows
was the advanced team for the uh
attempted corruption of the georgia
election by the trump administration he
went first in december
last minute to meet with cobb county
officials she was with him she arranged
that meeting and this was all the lead
up to the famous infamous january second
phone call involving trump so she was
there for that as a historical figure
she's also testified that she watched
and listened to trump in the dining room
of the of the um of the oval office off
the oval office with her boss mark
meadows in which mark meadows talked
about the chanting at the riot of the
jan 6 insurrection to hang mike pence
and him basically trump saying basically
that's a good idea so she heard that now
to the twitter verse that says or to
congress people that don't like her
testimony that says well she didn't
really uh she's not a good witness for
this because it's hearsay it's not
there's a hearsay exception if you
overhear somebody plotting a crime that
is what we call an admission against
interest that is a non-hearsay statement
she's completely qualified having heard
it to testify about it the reason why
this is happening i think today is is uh
several fold one she had a
always trumper as her lawyer until about
a month ago she then retained a very
confident and well-respected lawyer
his name is joseph hunt he goes by jody
jody hunt at austin and byrd a very
conservative law firm i know them well
in the white collar department
what's his link to all of this he was
jeff sessions
chief of staff so he knows what it means
to be a chief of staff we all know jeff
sessions was no big fan of donald trump
and was eventually exited from the
department of justice by donald trump
and he was also a jody hunt was also the
chief of the civil rights division for
two years under under trump he's a
quality guy he is a
sober and mature individual and i am
sure he convinced his client that the
best strategy for her especially with
the georgia grand jury out there was to
cooperate cooperate cooperate with the
gen 6 committee and i think now
jody in combination with the committee
has decided that she's in harm's way
because she is such a critical witness
having given this testimony they need to
take her off the street they need to
bring her in she's now willing under
jody hunt's guidance to give live
testimony which is much more powerful
than clips upon clips upon clips of her
previous 40 hours of testimony and
that's the reason they're doing it but
that's not the only thing that's going
on today i don't think i think they're
going to couple it with the
documentarian footage
which they've been pouring over over the
last 30 days
from alex holder the british
documentarian who has 11 hours of video
of not only the trumps the kids
in jan 5 jan 6 and gen 7. but way back
on september 29th before the first
debate with biden why does that matter
because bannon
and the trumpers
were already conspiring on tape on
record as not going to respect the
outcome of the election to call it a
fraud and to throw it to the house
in september and and i think we're going
to see some video clip from that as well
but even if we only see cassidy
hutchinson as a preview for the
early july hearings i think the reason
is changing council got to get her off
the street powerful testimony before the
fourth of july break
i i i tend to agree about the footage
part now i'm not sure exactly if we'll
see footage today but
some of the clips that we have um
you know been released um out there in
the space one with trump um one with
pence one with ivanka trump it seems
that maybe they will use her to
corroborate what is happening inside
that footage that we may view today um
as as sidebars like was this happening
here was this happening here we see this
here so i you know she is
supposedly um a very close aide to mark
meadows so she would be standing with
him in proximity of him and
the number one aide she was chief of
staff and his his right hand right so so
when when these conversations are
happening in the room with donald trump
and mark meadows about the election um
she is right there with them
listening to their every word and as we
know in politics in washington and
really any state house the aides
sometimes know more than the actual
official themselves just because um they
see all the background stuff not just
the foreground with the official or the
elected official or appointed official
um they they
to your point to your point john dean he
of white house fame and infamy he went
to jail as white house counsel but has
now rehabilitated himself as a political
commentator he made the good point on
his twitter feed yesterday that said the
only time there was an emergency hearing
a surprise witness at watergate was to
have one of the aides come forward with
the bombshell that nixon was recording
audio
24 7 in the white house we all know that
now but there was actually a witness who
came forward in an emergency hearing
just like that to talk about it i think
that
potentially cassidy hutchinson could be
just as powerful especially if it's
combined with the secret footage of the
documentarian that no one's ever seen
before
i i think i think i think that's a good
analysis of where they're going with
this also i think the reason why this is
so urgent is because there's
been reports that there are a lot of
threats on her life um there seems to be
even more security um today at some of
these hearings i guess that's some of
the reports that there's even heavier
security now because of this witness and
i i don't believe it's because of
her it's because of what she knows and
what she can testify to
is what they're terrified of and i think
that's why the security is ramped up i
think that's why they wanted to rush her
to get her testimony before she changes
her mind or someone else were to change
her mind um do you think witness
tampering's gonna come into this at all
no i think she's made the decision that
um having switched lawyers back to the
switch of the lawyers having gone with
with jodie hunt
she has made the decision that it is in
her best interest
and she's in a perilous position because
she could be um
prosecuted a part of the grand jury in
georgia for whatever her role was in
setting up those things or at least
being a witness to all of it she is
trying to get herself out of harm's way
i don't believe that she's she's she's
succumbing to
trump acolytes calling her tweeting
against her but there are crazies that
are on the fringes of the right wing
that i'm sure having learned because
it's been public in the last four months
in last month that she's given at least
four depositions and little there have
been clips already released by the gen 6
committee so anybody like the midas
mighty that are following this thing
closely on the right wing know that she
you know in their view stepped out of
bounds and is going against
you know their cult leader donald trump
so i'm sure she has gotten
a fair amount of terrible terrible
violent sexually violent things in
addition sent to her that have concerned
her i think that's only going me i think
that's only going to make her more
courageous to step forward and do the
right thing and say what she saw she
thought she's a witness she you know
hopefully she didn't do many of the bad
things that we've talked about already
well i i appreciate your commentary pop
as always thank you for joining us um
and speaking of switching lawyers
because i think that's a big deal i'm
going to switch to another lawyer here
um your co-host ben mizel so thank you
popock for for joining us thank you very
much
ben ben i want to bring you in here uh
ben how are you
i'm doing good i guess pope didn't get
the dress code memo huh not well no this
is pope p.i on vacation
oh he's on vacation i guess but but you
know we we are we are we are giving
commentary here so what what do you make
of this what do you make of this uh ben
about the switching lawyers and the rush
the rush to
to a hearing here because
it really was yesterday uh everyone was
playing committee clue it seemed like on
twitter and online who is it who's it
going to be is it going to be this
person is going to be that person and
then we find out that it is a aid to the
former chief of staff mark meadows and
some people kind of felt like at first
womp womp womp
but as we start to dig in
um and as we start to look at who she is
what she would know and then the events
that's happened over the last few weeks
we begin it becomes more clear why she
may know some things that they're scared
of what do you make of all the switch
and the urgency to rush to this hearing
well she definitely knows some things
but what is frightening here
is that it's obvious her life is being
threatened as the january 6th committee
has
increasingly proven to be successful
has been exposing trump trump is a maga
for the fascist cult that it is
the same tactics that lead to mob
violence
on january 6 that same mentality when
all the other tricks
and chicanery fail you threaten people's
lives that's what cults do that's what
magga does because it is a despicable
disgusting fascist movement that people
need to take seriously and the media
needs to stop both sides
and we need to focus far less on whether
rudy giuliani was tapped on the back
which the media has called an assault
which is complete [ __ ] and we should
focus on the fact that fascism
is creeping into our country and so what
today is about in my view is that there
is a legitimate fear
that her life is on the line and they
need her testimony immediately and i
know that sounds chilling and that may
sound frightening to those listening but
that we know from prior testimony the
threats to people's lives that are
taking place so that's one of the
reasons with this specific witness who
as michael popock explained the previous
guest before me she switched lawyers
from a mag a cult
lawyer
to a lawyer who by the way the lawyer
that now represents her
by all means is what traditionally was
viewed as a conservative lawyer it's not
a liberal lawyer or a left-leaning
lawyer even though to me and those who
watch the midas touch podcast to me the
term conservative has completely lost
all meaning because of magga but she's
represented by a credible individual who
doesn't want our country to be overtaken
by fascism and i think we're going to
see
two things you know today we're gonna
see her compelling testimony because
through her as michael popock said she's
a real fly on the wall she was at every
single
mark meadows meeting
and she was the one taking notes for
mark meadows as his senior aide in every
meeting you know people on capitol hill
who i've talked to say that mark meadows
would refuse to be at a meeting in fact
without cassidy hutchinson present at
the meeting and taking notes for him
cassidy hutchins background by the way
she interned for ted cruz she interned
for other let me think you're trying to
see who else she uh interned for so i
can get you um some additional info
about her steve scalise so this is no
this is no liberal uh person um so
her testimony is going to be incredibly
credible everyone who knows cassidy
hutchinson who i've spoken to say that
she worked hard she took notes you know
at the end of the day she was not going
to break the law
which is why you're going to hear
credible testimony and here we really
have someone
i mean isn't it just so interesting that
cassidy hutchinson while all of these
fascist mega men
you know from
uh mark meadows you know to
uh
kevin mccarthy to all these you know
people who are involved are so chicken
[ __ ] to tell the truth you know and here
we have truly the epitome of democracy
the epitome of strength at cassidy
hutchinson so i'm excited to hear a
testimony and i think we're going to see
the video uh clips as well interspersed
so what the jan six committee's done an
incredible job at is telling the story
telling this narration you know and
keeping the audience's interest so we're
going to get really embedded in these
meetings
through her narrative and then i think
we're going to see the clips that the
john 6 committee has obtained you know
that's something i took away from the
last hearing
that was a planned hearing but it was
the one that was postponed is the
narrative in the story that the
witnesses told about the meeting where
donald trump was trying to get jeffrey
clark to be the ag right and may and i
think you're right that that this
hearing is going to tell that story of
these meetings that we know have
happened we've heard these happening but
really i think the most obvious
time period is what was happening during
the siege on the capitol and she knows
that because she was there she was right
there in the mix with
trump and meadows and i think that's the
aim here to get to trump's intent um
because
if we know
from someone who was standing there what
his intent was i believe that's gonna
get to the heart of it
i agree with you and look i think
trump's intent in terms of how
uh federal prosecutors would view intent
like federal prosecutors have prosecuted
people with
far less evidence than what we have now
with donald trump but because it's a
very unique situation where you have and
i always hate to even call him a
president but a former president who
still has a substantial following of 25
to 30 percent of the united states are
mega cult members who haven't been
deprogrammed you need to have the kind
of
the normal standards of criminal
prosecution of having
beyond a reasonable doubt evidence the
standard has to be like beyond a
reasonable doubt times 10 i think is
what the jan 6 committee is trying to
show merrick garland here um because
they while there shouldn't be political
considerations you know i of course
inevitably it's a very unique situation
where you have you know a president
that's uh
engaged in a coup in search of legal
theories as a federal district court
judge in california said so there's a
very unique situation but you know i
think today we're going to hear some
powerful bombshell testimony i think
today is going to be the most memorable
day yet ben i want to bring in someone
who's actually
worked against trump in the courts
and she's beat him in the courts with
some of his uh ndas and she's still
working hard to beat him i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring in jessica denson here um
jessica what do you make of
of
this this i i just wanna say it this
woman out front
and here we are
we we had women um that testified before
but not not a woman inside the circle of
trump yet this is the first woman inside
the circle of trump and it appears that
uh she's going to drop bombs
um on trump and the truth really what do
you make of her testimony and the
urgency
having having know how this
the trump circle kind of works
yeah um i i'm going to get back to your
answer and i want to pick up on two
threads that ben mentioned the first is
obviously what we left off off with last
week were these very powerful hearings
and then that momentum as we all know
got truncated by this horrific news from
the supreme court
and i just want to whether it is sheer
coincidence whether it is the the fact
of these witnesses needing to come
forward right now in this new
information or just the dexterity and
talent of this committee i really want
to commend them
for keeping this
narrative of trump's
transgressions top of mind for the
american public because we have we have
a fascist threat on two fronts we have a
fascist threat in our elected officials
that are have created this illegitimate
supreme court and are forcing these
draconian policies on the american
people pushing us back
decades if not centuries and then we
have the threat of impunity for fascists
impunity for wannabe dictators and
neither one of them is any less
threatening to our future as a free
people so i am so grateful to be here
with you today talking about this
january 6 committee in what was supposed
to be a break what is presumably a
holiday or the beginning of a holiday
for many i'm so grateful that we are
focused again on this urgent threat to
our future as a free world um on that
thread of women i think it's another
beautiful coincidence i mean here we are
again
just last week we had these two
extraordinary brave women coming forward
sharing their
very personal experiences real
experiences of being threatened by this
fascism threatened by these lies and
this
terrorism of this former president
followed up by this assault on women's
rights assault on women's autonomy on
women's very identity as a human being
and not not as some
property for man in society and then we
come forward into this week with as you
said tony the first woman in this trump
orbit in the trump orbit to come forward
for a live in-person testimony and i do
not think that is a coincidence i think
it's
um
it's very telling about
you know i love men but
women let's just be honest are the
highest species and there's something
about women that has that
about women that that enables us to have
that quality to come forward whether it
is to admit that we were wrong or to
have that courage to confront evil and
so um
i'm i'm really interested to see what
this young woman and think about this
this is a very young woman she did have
a pretty high up position in the trump
administration but as ben was saying she
was an intern before this in in office
she did not um i think she's in her
mid-20s at best so this is
this is a lot of weight on her a lot of
pressure on her when i came forward i'm
a very independent person and i know
that i know that what i did is not
something that most people
feel the freedom and the independence in
the context of their careers and you
know other social and political
pressures to do i understand that and
this woman with all of those
considerations that you know her future
her career is the first woman from
inside the trump orbit as you were
saying with all of these other men
refusing to come forward to step foot
live into that hearing room and tell the
american people what she knows
nothing to lose sight of i think i think
i think you're absolutely correct and
and the thing i think you're correct
about is that women are way better than
men that's what i i think that's that's
the part you're absolutely correct about
ben what what do you make of this being
the very first and i i know it's it it
seems like it may be obvious but i think
it's important that this is the very
first woman inside the trump orbit
because
we we saw the election worker and her
mother and in the testimony about the
grandmother and those those women's
testimony uh in front of the the select
committee but they weren't inside the
trump orbit they were the victim of the
people inside the trump orbit but now we
see the first the first woman stepping
forward in the hearing and being
questioned and giving her testimony um
what do you make of that do you think
that's significant i think it's
significant but i think it's obvious the
men in the trump orbit are chicken [ __ ]
that whole fascism that they have is all
whining and playing the victim and
that's what we see repeatedly with trump
they're coming after me
no this is about democracy at the end of
the day this is not a partisan issue and
so it doesn't surprise me that it is a
woman who
happened to be in the trump orbit just
because she interned and she was
pursuing a career that led her to be in
that place but who saw it
and called it out the same way jessica
called it out it's not it's not a
surprise that the common strain here is
that it's women who are calling it out
these trump men are not real men these
are disgusting people who try to project
the machismo but they're really pieces
of [ __ ] and i created this media company
midas media network so i can say stuff
like that that you can't necessarily say
on cnn or on the other networks but
that's what we talk about here that's
why they have the trump flags with the
six-pack
you know where he's got the six-pack abs
because they want to make themselves
feel like men because they are the
lowest form of freaking people these are
traitors to the country and we're going
to see a powerful woman stand up for our
democracy today well i i'm i'm excited
to to
get to her testimony i i'm very excited
to hear exactly what she has to say um
but i think
more than anything she's going to be
very believable
and jessica you've you've watched as
some of her testimony in tapes behind
closed doors has been played in some of
these hearings already i think she's
very believable she's very authentic
you see her sitting on the couch in some
of those clips
and she's just like the last week when
she was talking about the pardon she was
going on and and the best part was is
her authenticity towards marjorie taylor
green like no i didn't really want to
talk to her much anyways i think she's
going to come off as authentic just
seeing what we've what we've noticed in
the clips what's your what's your take
on
if she's gonna i think most women do
come off as authentic um but what what
do you think uh will be the auntie
um yeah yeah i mean i from my very
limited read i i do not know her um she
seems like i think the most
obvious thing about cassidy hutchinson
is you're gonna be able to tell she has
no agenda she is just as you were as we
were describing her she is the one who
was in the room um it's just it's going
to be just a very direct testimony that
is unfiltered and untainted
um and
yeah i i um
i think that's what that's what we can
expect
awesome well thank you thank you both
thank you ben for sticking around with
jessica and jessica thank you for
joining us and giving us the insight not
just from a woman's perspective
from a perspective that has fought the
trump uh orbit and is it just me or did
ben get some color in texas uh he must
have he must have been out there walking
walking them streets knocking on doors
gave him some some sun there you have a
response ben do you have a
i want to say this yeah i did get some
color but see that's one of the benefits
that you get to all the people watching
this right now you gotta walk the walk
as well in addition to talk to talk you
know i flew down to dallas i was
knocking on doors for beto and i
encourage everybody to get involved
whether it's writing postcards knocking
on doors spreading the midas touch
videos and everybody make sure you're
subscribed to the midas touch youtube
channel now where the fastest growing
independent media company in the world
and we're unapologetically pro-democracy
so subscribe now and make sure you get
out there and get out the message to all
your friends and family also i can't i
can't forget your your brother jordy is
making me do a commercial here for the
10 off the convict or convict 45 enamel
pens union made in the usa go to
store.minustouch.com promo code justice
jordy only has a few of these things
left over there so get them why while
supplies last just go to
store.minustouch.com use the promo code
justice for 10 off all merch
go over there and get a convict 45 or
convict 45 whichever way you look at it
grab grab your union made enamel pen
thank you jessica and thank you ben for
joining us uh speaking of texas i'm
going to go to texas paul here
um we got texas paul on the line i think
he's ready here he was having a little
bit of audio issues earlier but i think
he's good now texas paul how are you
i'm doing great how do i say oh you
sound fantastic you sound fantastic it's
a it's uh it's great to see you i know
ben was just talking about your home
state and beto and getting out and
working hard to knock the doors you were
at some of these events um if people go
to some of these pictures that the midas
mighty have been posting i can see the
cowboy hat and several of them so let's
let's first start off i wanna i wanna
say thank you to the minus mighty and
thank you to you for showing up and
getting out there and participating uh
just as ben said it's very important
that we participate in our democracy not
just talk about it so
those are the most wonderful people i
got to spend three four hours with them
after they had been out block walking
all day and and i i i was driving uh
trying to get there um i live
you know texas everything's hours away
from everything and
they had been out block walking all day
in
you know 100 degree heat
and got together and we're the liveliest
most wonderful people
i got to meet some of the best people i
swear to god it was more fun than a
barrel of monkeys man i'm telling you it
really was i mean and and you talk about
dedicated and fired up and and and ready
to go i mean everybody was just like i
mean it was there was no
working for conversation man they were
just chatter boxes you know
we're doing this and we're doing that
and the next event is on this day and
then oh my gosh
all the pictures they were posting i
think they said they knocked on like
1100 doors and they wrote 200 letters i
mean that that that that's a lot of
people to touch and if everyone does
their part out there and and it you know
really uses their talent i think we can
we can really um touch as many people as
possible and engage in our democracy
speaking of engaging in our democracy um
paul i think that's what we're going to
see today from this witness she's
engaging in her democracy she saw what
was happening she knows exactly what was
said about our democracy and how these
people were trying to tear it down and i
think today we're going to hear her
really torch these folks um give it to
us in your words though i know everyone
loves the texas paul touch here tell us
what you think this witness is going to
do to these mogalodites today
well you know first i'm going to start
with mark meadows mark meadows is the
biggest piece of [ __ ] there is on the
planet you know hillary clinton sat
under oath for 11 hours
answered every question mark meadows is
throwing
cassidy
hudson under the bus i mean just
throwing her right under the bus he
knows damn well what moga is going to do
to her
he knows that she has been loyal she's
she's my she has been straight up
margaret i mean look at that she worked
for ted cruz she worked for this is not
a left winger here folks this is
somebody that grew up in the
conservative movement
you know was her dream to work in this
white house and they are throwing her
under the bus because they are weakling
sorry pieces of garbage and there's just
no other way to put it she is going and
she's going to sit there under oath
she's got a good lawyer she's going to
tell
everything that happened
and mark meadows could have done this
mark meadows could have spared her this
100
you know she she would have not had the
death threats she her family wouldn't
have to put up the death threats
i mean they're gonna make her like
living hell because mark meadows is the
biggest
i won't use the p word because the
ladies get mad at me but you know
exactly what i'm thinking
well i i think i think um the word that
they used that trump called pence was
wimp i think that's what you're what
you're getting yeah we'll go with win
not strong enough but we'll go with it
right right right
i i i appreciate the uh the strong
language you know i i like to use uh
strong language and i think we are going
to see today her testify to the strong
language of these morons in this room
during the siege on the capital of what
their language was we already know that
there's reports of her witnessing trump
cheering that they were
talking about hanging and i'm talking
about uh the army of of morons that he
you know
sent to our capital to take away our
democracy i believe that
um you're going to see her describe in a
lot of words
exactly how the president united states
was cheering that his supporters
were chanting hang my pence in that
moment because he was terrified that
mike pence wouldn't do what he wanted
him to do which he knew was illegal
everyone knew was illegal
i mean even even last the last hearing
we
we heard from uh rosen and donahue the
acting attorney general and deputy
attorney general who was in the room
stephen engel even who was in the room
as donald trump was trying his damnedess
to find anyone even if he had to make
jeffrey clark this buffoon the attorney
general um but i think we're gonna hear
more about those meetings today and what
the details were and i don't think she's
going to hold back at all uh she may
just go all texas paul on the hearing
room today i don't know she is going to
tell us
everything she was in the room for
i would probably guess 98 of the
meetings that they had and you know
because it's it's it's a well-known
you know fact that
mark meadows did not want to step into a
meeting without her being there she was
his memory his his hit i mean his record
she's going to sit down and she's going
to tell it all and that's why i have to
tell you it pisses me off so damn bad we
democrats don't do this we don't throw
our freaking staff under the bus we
stand up and say we did this and we
believed we we did this because we
believed it was the right thing to do if
you're sitting there declaring the fifth
freaking amendment or trying to hide
behind hide behind presidential
privilege does not exist in a crime
there's no such thing as presidential
privilege in the commission of a crime
so mark meadows is sitting there like
the biggest piece of [ __ ] that he is and
throwing cassidy hutchison under the bus
because he's too damn scared
to face the manga freaks that are out
there that that the bottom line that is
it there is no other reason he could
possibly give because he's not spared
from incrimination
everything hutchinson said is what he is
going to say
there is no reason other than he is a
complete and utter power
well i appreciate your commentary uh
paul and and i i know everyone
appreciates that you don't hold back uh
thank you for joining us here today
stick around because i know you you'll
be able to give commentary hopefully in
the middle if we have a break and then
at the very end now thank you texas paul
yes can i have one thing yes go ahead
the mine is mighty down
in that gathering it came out that the
mighty mighty down here in texas have
knocked on any door on on more doors for
betto than any other organization out
there getting help they have knocked on
more doors than anyone else they are bad
ass to the extreme and i'll tell you
what
tony yes we're not that far you need to
come down and party with these people oh
okay they are fun people man i'm telling
you all day long out 100 degree heat
they got together and man we were uh
you just got to ask ben about it it was
a blast and jordy jordy had a good time
i i i appreciate i appreciate everyone
down there in texas working hard to save
our democracy um i want to go to another
midas money thank you paul for joining
us i want to go to another midas mighty
favorite uh karen agnipolo from legal af
um karen uh how are you today let's see
let's get there we go hey karen how are
you hi i'm good how are you i'm i'm
doing fantastic what do you make of this
witness and all the drama that has led
up to this in the last you know 16 hours
18 hours or so and
i i think um because i think we even
were texting back and forth like who is
this person who is this witness going to
be then we've again like i told ben
earlier we found out it kind of felt
underwhelming at first but then once you
dive into it and you get into who she is
what she knows and then the
circumstances over the last few weeks
um from a prosecutor's standpoint
because that's really what i want to get
from you from a prosecutor's standpoint
what do you think this means i mean is
this significant that she's coming
forward and the committee is rushing to
hear her testimony in public
yeah so you know i i can't help but i i
can't help but have the song from
hamilton did you watch it do you ever
see hamilton the the broadway show i i
can't help
okay well i can't get the song out of my
head you know she was in the room where
it happened you know
because boy was she in the room where it
happened and that that is sort of who
she is you know michael popock said it
perfectly she's the proverbial fly on
the wall
and
so
what was very interesting about this
emergency surprise hearing whatever you
want to call it
is you know i i think there's still
going to be a lot of surprises because
don't forget she has testified already
on what four depositions so it's not
like she hasn't
been before the committee and it's not
like we haven't heard from her from the
committee so what's new what's the
emergency well what's the surprise what
is she going to come up with that she
hasn't come up with before or said
before
that's what i think is going to be very
interesting about
today's hearing you know it can't just
be will live testimony is more powerful
than
than taped testimony because again they
would have known that already and
planned for that already there's
something has happened
and it could be
that she's had threats that's one
possibility and so she wants to get her
statement out there
now
it also could be that she sees the
writing on the wall which is you know
the department of justice i think is
doing
you know is clearly doing an
investigation and and this sort of
circle is tightening right you know we
we saw the the warrant being
served on john eastman uh in that video
and we obviously heard about it uh in
his filing that he
that he filed you know we wouldn't have
known about this about john eastman for
example had he not brought it to our
attention because law enforcement didn't
say anything about it so for all we know
law enforcement is circling in on
mark meadows or cassidy hutchinson or we
just don't know and it's very clear to
me that the department of justice is
watching these hearings and
ramping up their investigation based on
partly things that are coming out at the
hearing you know because it's they're
not waiting they are
serving subpoenas um they're they're
serving warrants you know the eastman
was a warrant and
i just found that that very interesting
because a lot of white-collar
investigations what what the fbi and the
department of justice will sometimes do
is allow
people to um they could have subpoenaed
his phone right and they could have
had let him turn it over but no they did
the surprise we're going to show up with
a warrant and put your hands on top of
your head and take your phone because
we're worried that you're going to
destroy information and again they are
that means to me they are intensely
intensely investigating this case and
it's heating up and so i think that's
what's coming what what this is related
to i think that that the the the circle
of prosecution is tightening around the
trump inner circle
and she has information and she doesn't
want to go to prison i mean she i think
is a true believer and was a true
believer
but not to the point of going
you know going to
going to prison uh for the on their
behalf and i think that's where it's
where it's heading
so let me ask you real quick with one
one more question to that aim is do you
think that um possibly cassidy hudson
thinks hey maybe i have or this new
attorney has said hey you might have
some criminal liability here if you are
not and maybe protecting herself
in a way of saying hey i i cooperated i
cooperated to the fullest extent if she
would ever see that criminal liability
in a court somewhere do you think that's
part of it or do you just think
um that she doesn't want anything to do
with a criminal prosecution at all
rather she's the the target or a witness
i mean obviously she's going to be a
witness here but what what what what do
you say to that
look nobody wants to be part of a
criminal prosecution nobody nobody wants
to be a witness and be cross-examined
and go through that whether you like you
know whether whether
you like the person or just dislike the
person it's it's not a fun experience
i'm sure she doesn't want to but you
know the criminal justice system doesn't
work that way you if you have evidence
in a case and uh they know you have
evidence in a case you have no choice
but to testify of course you can take
the fifth um you know but that's sort of
um
you know that that's neither here nor
there i think she
uh
i think she potentially well for sure we
know she's a witness right for sure she
saw people burning you know um
burning you know documents um
the whole you know hang mike pence and
trump saying that's a good idea you know
the chanting i mean you know all of that
is clearly she's a witness right and so
she has information whether she could
potentially be prosecuted herself i
don't know and that'll be interesting to
see
um but i'm like i said i'm just curious
what's the emergency what's the new
information that
required to be called for a new hearing
because they've heard from her at least
four times so something has happened
from the time that she's testified to
today
and it's going and and i don't know what
that is it could be that she's had a
change of heart and
you know she
has information that she was scared to
give before or didn't want to give
before and now she does it could be that
the prosecution's heating up and it's
gotten close to her it could be these
threats you know and she's she's just
sort of needs to get her statement out
there it could be that you know she's
had a complete change of heart and she
suddenly wants to do the right thing
i have no idea but something has
happened between then and now and i
think that's going to be what the
bombshell is that at least i'm looking
forward to
to seeing today because it's a pretty
big deal
well thank you karen for joining us i
appreciate it i want to go to the thank
you for joining us as always and if you
can stick around um we'd love to hear
if we get uh time in the middle or at
the end what some of your analysis of
her testimony is thank you karen for
joining us um i want to bring in the the
politics of this although because we've
heard from a few attorneys here about
the the legal aspect i want to bring in
some folks that know about the politics
some political strategist here uh david
bender and one of my favorite political
strategists sorry david um dr rachel
biddikover uh thank you thank you for
joining us sorry david i i i i love you
to death but rachel is is my favorite
political strategist she knows she knows
from i'm leaving i'm leaving now
you do that and
he wins the hat race though well
well well thank you for that and rachel
i defer to you as i understand it uh
this witness was one of your students is
that right
yeah yeah and you know what's
sad is i'm really bad with names so it
never registered to me i followed the
day-to-day on the
on the um you know investigation and so
i knew that i had read you know a
witness cassidy hutchinson had changed
her
legal team away and and divested her
legal representation away from the trump
world and
so uh but but then it was when we had
the last hearing and they showed the
video and i i was i looked at the screen
and i was like oh oh
that's my student and
that was crashing back i mean it's so
it's such an unfortunate thing because
this kid was very she's very bright she
was in my quant class and um you know
she she was obviously well connected
because she told me she was graduating
and going to work on in steve scalise's
office which is of course you know what
that he's he's he was he's in the
republican leadership
that's a very prestigious posting for a
fresh out of college
student so generally speaking when my
better connected students are going off
into trump world i always gave him sage
advice which was you know don't commit
any crimes
[Laughter]
let's let's uh just for the information
and i think uh people didn't know i
didn't know this was you were teaching
christopher newport university
in virginia and this is where she
graduated and she's very
still very young this is 2018
yes guys yes i mean i'm so i'm actually
a little glad to like i don't know her i
mean she was a student in my class we
got along i connected and mentored many
young conservatives uh which is kind of
funny because you know the university
pushes me out
um but you know i was i was a good
mentor to the young republicans because
let me tell you
like that's the future if we win right
we have to we can't just blow up we must
fix right and so i always like to make
good relationships with my conservative
students and try to steer them a little
bit away from the radicalism that's you
know the other side of youth con the
youth conservative movement the turning
point usa side is radical as [ __ ] you're
the most important person now today in
anyone doing analysis before she speaks
because you know her yeah and and in
saying that here she is doing
she did it for 20 hours and four
depositions she's done the right thing
yeah she stood up against what must be a
tremendous amount of pressure
this is no doubt i'm so glad that you're
saying that because it's coming from
someone else and not just me
like i want people to understand what
put yourself in the shoes of a kid for a
shot of out of out of college right
you're 22 23 years old
you're getting on you're on this
promotion like um locomotive too because
the trump trump world was weird like
that i mean because nobody really have
nobody wanted to go to jail
so they
so like you could move that ladder up
really [ __ ] quick you know
she stayed longer than most i mean
because mark meadows was there for
longer than five minutes she was she was
his right hand yeah for a
long relatively long period of time in
prep world which is more than a week
you guys all see saw her care i don't
have to actually attest to her character
because i think everyone saw it in that
deposition they aired last time when
they asked her about marjorie taylor
green and she
look on her face was like yeah i don't i
don't talk to it tomorrow i don't talk
to her
exactly right but we didn't know we
didn't know until late last night uh and
they did do a close hold and i think
one can reasonably assess that the close
hold is not only because of what she's
going to say
but because the pressure on her if this
was two weeks from now it would be
tremendous not to do it and they'd start
savaging
her reputation yes saying that she you
know all of the things that one can say
to marginalize a witness and
particularly a young woman
believe me they would do it and so
getting her out there quickly makes a
lot of sense they had to bring members
of congress back
from recess i mean adam schiff flying
cross-country was cheney flying cross
country
there's a reason they did this this
quickly they didn't want to use this
moment
yeah there's some i mean it's got to be
good
that's what i think
you know i mean the committee
if the committee had been run
differently and like it was run in so
many ways our democratic stuff is run
without like a media strategy that
that's not the case here there's been a
very competent very effective media
comms component of this and so you just
know the committee understands
expectations
you know and uh they knew that to call
an emergency session 24 hours away not
later in the week but right away was
going to raise expectations both about
who the witness was right and i think it
was good to get out who it was because
expectations on that the speculation was
causing expectations to get even my own
expectations to get very high you know
all of
but i think it's important to lower
those expectations and to realize that
what may
be happening here is not so much
anything new
and it's possible
but that if we're thinking about the
reality of this young woman this fresh
out of college essentially she's had
jobs she had scalise then she went to
ted cruz think of think of that
but she was
her
her life in the world is really
relatively brief as an adult she's still
a very young woman who is about to go on
the national stage
and you know what that's going to do and
i feel for her i really do
greatly and i think the committee
understood there must have been
negotiations uh tell me
rachel uh tony if you heard what i heard
in the voice off camera when she's doing
the deposition it's a woman talking i
think it's liz cheney asking her those
questions
i i felt the same way yes i think it was
liz cheney uh off when when they're
talking about the pardons and she's
sitting on the couch it sounded like it
sounded like darth vader jr i mean liz
cheney to me
you know like i call her darth vader jr
um but i i do i do believe that it was
liz cheney i think that's very important
um and i think that was sending signals
because let's talk about the politics of
this of what could be the political
ramifications of today because we've
watched
rachel you can confirm or deny this for
me but the generic ballot is moving and
it seems like it's moving in the correct
direction for democracy here um it is a
slight movement and it's slow but it
seems like people are finally picking up
on what has happened what these people
tried to do to our democracy and why
it's so important it's so important to
engage and know exactly the facts and
act on those facts tell us about the
politics i'll start with rachel tell me
about the politics of this and what it
means today
in in the political body of the country
i mean we're really a tale of two cities
here we're in a world that's well known
where fundamentals in party and out
party fundamentals predict election
outcomes and when you couple them with
[ __ ] [ __ ] economic indicators
like recession and inflation high gas
yeah you know it's not good right but
we've got these two intervening
variables i mean it takes something
titanic
to be an intervening variable the court
curtailing row would not have been a
good enough it would take a full
evisceration and that's why i know mitch
mcconnell was like damn wish we would
have caught that car
next year not this year right so um you
know we're really talking about we don't
we don't know and and and we
we want to see data you refer to the
generic ballot we don't know if that's
moving yet we we think we might see
movement but we don't actually know we
won't know until we look at the
aggregated generics in a few days we
should start to see the movement though
rachel did you see a marist poll that
came out
uh i saw it yesterday and and i i'd like
to see it it was sent to me and i want
to see if it's accurate it was a marist
nbc poll that showed the generic
flipping 12 points
uh
in in terms of a democratic advantage
now of seven
and having been down five in the last
marist poll head to head uh yeah i'm
definitely i mean you know
i don't love marist either but still no
i mean it's not even that i mean it's
like i don't love any single indicator
you know what i mean like so like you
know so we'll know i mean we're gonna
know guys and i know we want to know now
because we're americans and we're used
to knowing [ __ ] before it happens right
but the fact is we can't know until the
data gets fielded and collected and
comes from what you're seeing right now
are going to be the online panels the
large
larger panel studies are going to start
to come out
and we just we need to give it a week
and we'll have a better sense of the
data but i don't i try not to look at
any one indicator like that especially
for something we're talking about
did the generic ballot to put this frame
of reference we we started in the fall
talking and bitching about internal
party fighting about buildback better
and sausage making it was just a shitty
media environment and then it switched
to ukraine and and then the gm6 [ __ ] and
the generic ballot has never moved
through any of it nothing until this row
thing if it does move it's predominantly
coming from row that doesn't mean that
the jn6 [ __ ] isn't important it is
because it's gonna give us the ability
to take these top line
like you know the the whole contextual
story and give it a compelling
you know narration to the to the voting
electorate using this material but at
the end of the day well if we're going
to see stuff it's going to be because of
roe
tell me if you agree with this and tony
and i have been talking about this
offline a good bit
on friday it occurred to me that we
finally have proof of what donald trump
did not just
through january 6th and and trying to
overthrow the constitution he is
undermining the constitution with three
appointments the supreme court that's
his legacy
and
the hashtag that came to me was trump
court
that's what it is now and people like
lawrence tribe and normizen and others
have been putting that forward in the
world
but tell me if you agree uh rachel that
that connecting up the anger that people
feel about
this court and not only what it's done
but what it said it's going to do yeah
with all the other cases on the docket
2324
2223 next year
isn't trump court
the essence of focusing people's anger
on this man not just for january 6 but
for what he is doing to the constitution
and the country
yeah i mean it can be what you'd have to
you'd have to check around like
do some testing on that here's my
problem with trump instead of republican
it's like
they don't
what we want to be doing is they want to
be branding the whole party as trump so
i you know the problem when you when you
rely exclusively on a past president as
your brander now you're giving up some
of that power and where their power is
the most significant against us is that
broad brush it's all of us we're all
groomers there's no such thing as a
moderate democrat they're all
rabid breathing you know
foaming socialists that want to steal
all your [ __ ] right so like if we if we
brand everything trump then trump
becomes a a like a cancerous cell in an
otherwise healthy party and that's not
what we have
right
in the short term mcconnell's [ __ ]
magic in the short term though in the
short term there is a goal here and
there's a goal that we're trying to
create a climate in which
60 plus percent of the country think and
right now it's moving that direction
it's not there yet
think that this man should be indicted
and as i say justice is blind but this
is how justice is blind
justice will appear through her fingers
and merit garland is the one peering
through those fingers so if he sees that
uh trump is associated not just with
what we're going to see in this
committee
and what we're going to see in the
evidence but what
he did and people are really genuinely
angry about that that's going to create
a climate in the short term there's a
consequence not even the election in
november
in getting those indictments
and one of the things we've heard so
many times is that
the politics of doing indictments
against this former president will
divide the country and the argument i
make is that if the country is not
divided if it's 60 to 65 percent in
favor of it that makes it a lot easier
well it doesn't matter ultimately what
what should matter to merrick garland is
this stark and harsh reality life is
brutish nasty and short merit okay and
here's your two options you can either
indict a former president and deal with
the political fallout that that is no
doubt going to create or you can just
allow the rule of law to die in america
and allow the constitution to die so
like you know i feel like yeah it's it's
a tough it's a tough decision but the
only thing worse than prosecuting trump
and the rest of the coup plotters is not
doing exactly cannot have a stable
functioning democracy after that so he
really to me
doesn't have a lot of choice and he
seems like a guy that's gonna get that
but i'll never trust anyone again after
robert mueller
fair point and that's again why making
this as
broad-based as possible creating a
popular consensus that this is the right
thing to do that's what the committee's
job is and anything that can be done to
help it that's why i think keeping the
pressure on trump in the short term in
this next three to four months is
crucial long before we get to november
now's the time
and and am i correct i'm seeing people
gathering have they have they started
walking yet yes they they they haven't
brought the witness and i i i think that
there's been a lot of extra security at
the hearing today the report so we may
be just a few minutes over here because
of some of these uh
it looks like they're photographing now
so it looks like the witness is going to
enter i know there's there is
yeah
he's running late
we'll be able to hear the audio the
whole time on this
thing absolutely yeah all right
otherwise i'm out of here man
this is a must-see [ __ ] tv
right here boys we will be able to i
think
the other uh rachel brought it up
earlier is like young younger people who
are getting uh well they're gonna speak
i'll bring it up later
oh man she looks great
i'm having just a few difficulties here
hey everyone
hey gabe how you guys doing
you're looking great today is anything
going on
uh it looks like tony is getting your
feet ready here we go there we go
looks like we're gonna gavel in thank
you for joining us everybody
the select committee to investigate the
january sixth attack
on the united states capitol will be in
order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material presented
during this hearing
good afternoon
in our hearings over the previous weeks
the select committee has laid out the
details of a multi-part pressure
campaign
driven by the former president aimed at
overturning the results of the 2020
presidential election
and blocking the transfer of power
we've shown that this effort was based
on a lie a lie that the election was
stolen
tainted by widespread fraud
donald trump's big lie
in the weeks ahead the committee will
hold additional hearings about how
donald trump
summoned a mob of his supporters to
washington
spurred them to march on the capitol and
failed to take meaningful action to
quell the violence as it was unfolding
on january 6th
however in recent days the select
committee has obtained new information
dealing with what was going on in the
white house on january 6
and in the days prior
specific detailed information about
what the former president and his top
aides were doing and saying
in those critical hours
firsthand details of what transpired in
the office of the white house chief of
staff
just steps from the oval office as the
threats of violence became clear
and indeed violence ultimately descended
on the capitol
in the attack on american democracy
it's an important it's important that
the american people hear that
information immediately that's why in
consultation with the vice chair
i've recalled the committee for today's
hearing
as you've seen and heard in our earlier
hearings the select committee has
developed a massive body of evidence
thanks to the many hundreds of witnesses
who have voluntarily provided
information relevant to our
investigation
it hasn't always been easy to get that
information
because the same people who drove the
former president's pressure campaign
to overturn the election are now trying
to cover up the truth about january 6.
but thanks to the courage of certain
individuals the truth won't be buried
the american people won't be left in the
dark
our witness today miss cassie hutchinson
has embodied that courage i won't get
into a lot of detail about miss
hutchinson's testimony we'll show
i'll allow her words to speak for
themselves and i hope everyone at home
will listen very closely
first i recognize our distinguished vice
chair ms cheney of wyoming for any
opening statement she care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
in our first five hearings the committee
has heard from a significant number of
republicans including former trump
administration justice department
officials trump campaign officials
several members of president trump's
white house staff
prominent conservative judge and several
others
today's witness is cassidy hutchinson is
another republican and another former
member of president trump's white house
staff
certain of us in the house of
representatives recall that miss
hutchinson once worked for house
republican whip steve scalise
but she is also a familiar face on
capitol hill because she held a
prominent role in the white house
legislative affairs office and later was
the principal aide to president trump's
chief of staff mark meadows
ms hutchinson has spent considerable
time up here on capitol hill
representing the trump administration
and we welcome her back
up until now our hearings have each been
organized to address specific elements
of president trump's plan to overturn
the 2020 election
today we are departing somewhat from
that model
because ms hutchinson's testimony
touches on several important and
cross-cutting topics
topics that are relevant to each of our
future hearings
in her role working for the white house
chief of staff ms hutchinson handled a
vast number of sensitive issues
she worked in the west wing several
steps down the hall from the oval office
ms hutchinson spoke daily with members
of congress with high-ranking officials
in the administration
with senior white house staff including
mr meadows
with white house counsel lawyers and
with mr tony ornato who served as the
white house deputy chief of staff
she also worked on a daily basis with
members of the secret service who were
posted in the white house
in short miss hutchinson was in a
position to know a great deal about the
happenings in the trump white house
ms hutchinson has already sat for four
videotaped interviews with committee
investigators and we thank her very much
for her cooperation and for her courage
we will cover certain but not all
relevant topics within ms hutchinson's
knowledge today
again our future hearings will supply
greater detail putting the testimony
today in a broader and more complete
context
today you will hear ms hutchinson relate
certain first-hand observations of
president trump's conduct on january 6.
you will also hear new information
regarding the actions and statements of
mr trump's senior advisors that day
including his chief of staff mark
meadows and his white house counsel
and we will begin to examine evidence
bearing on what president trump and
members of the white house staff knew
about the prospect for violence on
january 6th even before that violence
began
to best communicate the information the
committee has gathered we will follow
the practice of our recent hearings
playing videotape testimony from ms
hutchinson and others and also posing
questions to ms hutchinson live
mr chairman i yield back
thank you very much our witness today is
miss cassie hutchinson who served in the
trump administration in the white house
office of legislative affairs from 2019
to 2020 and as a special assistant to
the president in the white house chief
of staff's office from march 2020
through january
2021 i will now sweat in our witness the
witness will please stand and raise her
right hand
do you swear affirm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated
as a record reflect the witness answered
in the affirmative
i now recognize myself for questions
mrs hutchinson i'd like to start with a
few questions about your background
the
these are some photographs we've
obtained highlighting your career
these show
you as members of congress including
steve
scalise
as well as the white house with leader
kevin mccarthy and jim jordan
others show you with the president
and members of congress aboard air force
one
before you worked in the white house
you worked on capitol hill for
representative steve scalise the
republican whip and senator ted cruz
and then in 2019 you moved to the white
house and served there until the end of
the trump administration
in
2020 when you started at the white house
you served at in the office of
legislative affairs
we understand that you were initially
hired as a staff assistant
but was soon promoted to a position of
greater responsibility
can you explain your role for the
committee
when i moved over to the white house
chief of staff's office with mr meadows
when he became the fourth chief of staff
it's difficult to describe a typical day
um i was a special assistant to the
president and an advisor advisor to the
chief of staff
the days depended on what the president
was doing that day and that's kind of
how my portfolio was reflected i had a
lot of outreach with members of congress
senior cabinet cabinet officials
we would work out work on policy issues
with relevant internal components and
members on the hill
as well as security protocol
at the white house complex for mr
meadows and the president
and then you were
you received another promotion in march
2020
at that time you became the principal
aide to the new white house chief of
staff mark meadows is that right that's
correct sir
what did a typical day look like for you
in your work with mr meadows
it varied with what was going on we
spent a lot of time on the hill i spent
time on the hill independently too as i
was his liaison for capitol hill
um
we did a lot of presidential travel
engagements but mostly i was there to
serve what the chief of staff needed and
a lot of times what the chief of staff
needed was a reflection of what the
president's schedule is detailed to do
that day
so is it fair to say that you spoke
regularly in your position both with
members of congress and with senior
members of the trump administration
that's correct that's a fair assessment
sir
and would you say that in your work with
mr meadows you are typically in contact
with him and others in the white house
throughout the day
that's correct sir mr meadows and i were
in contact
almost
pretty much throughout every day
consistently
although so much of grave importance
happens in the west wing of the white
house
it's a quite a small building
above me
on the screen
you can see a map of the first floor
of the west wing of the white house
on the right
you can see the president's oval office
on the left
the chief of staff's office suite
within the chief of staff office suite
is the heart of the west wing
was your desk
which was between the vice president's
office this kirschner's office and the
oval office
ms hutchinson is
this an accurate depiction of where you
were located
it's accurate
it's a lot smaller than it looks
absolutely
uh
mr this is a photo that shows the short
distance
between your office and the president's
oval office
and it only takes five to ten seconds or
so to walk down the hall
from your office to the oval office is
that right that's correct
thank you pursuant to the section 5c 8
of house resolution 503 the chair
recognizes gentlewoman from wyoming miss
cheney for questions
thank you very much mr chairman
mr chairman we will begin today with an
exchange that first provided ms
hutchinson a tangible sense of the
ongoing planning for the events of
january 6th
on january 2nd four days before the
attack on our capitol president trump's
lead lawyer mr giuliani was meeting with
white house chief of staff mark meadows
and others
ms hutchinson do you remember mr
giuliani meeting with mr meadows on
january 2nd 2021
i do he met with mr meadows in the
evening of january 2nd 2021
and we understand that you walked mr
giuliani out of the white house that
night um and he talks to you about
january 6th what do you remember him
saying
as mr giuliani and i were walking to his
vehicles that evening
he looked at me and said something to
the effect of
cash are you excited for the sixth it's
going to be a great day
i remember looking at him saying rudy to
explain what's what's happening on the
six
uh he and he had responded something to
the effect of we're going to the capitol
it's going to be great
the president's going to be there he's
going to look powerful he's he's going
to be with the members he's going to be
with the senators talk to the chief
about it talk to the chief about it he
knows about it
and did you go back uh then up to the
west wing and tell mr meadows about your
conversation with mr giuliani i did
after mr giuliani had left the campus
that evening i went back up to our
office and i found mr meadows in his
office on the couch
he was scrolling through his phone i
remember leaning against the doorway and
saying i had an interesting conversation
with rudy mark
sounds like we're going to go to the
capitol
he didn't look up from his phone and
said something to be effective
there's a lot going on cass
but i don't know
things might get real real bad on
january 6.
uh miss hutchinson mr meadows is engaged
in litigation with the committee to try
to avoid testifying here
um what what was your
action when he said to you things might
get real real bad
in the days before january 2nd
i was apprehensive about the sixth i had
heard general plans for a rally uh i had
heard tentative movements to potentially
go to the capitol
but
when hearing rudy's take on january 6
and then mark's response
that was the first that evening was the
first moment
that i remember feeling
scared
and
nervous for what could happen on january
6th
and i had a deeper concern for
what was
happening
with the planning aspects of it
thank you miss edgeson today we're going
to be focusing primarily on the events
of january 5th and 6th at the white
house
but to begin and to frame the discussion
i want to talk about a conversation that
you had with mr john ratcliffe
the director of national intelligence
and uh you had this conversation in
december of 2020.
mr ratcliffe was nominated by president
trump
to oversee u.s intelligence our u.s
intelligence community
and before his appointment mr ratcliffe
was a republican member of congress
as you will see on this clip director
ratcliffe's comments in december of 2020
were prescient
my understanding was mr iraq director
radcliffe
didn't want much to do
with the post election period
joshua felt that
it wasn't something that the white house
should be pursuing
i felt it was dangerous for the
president's legacy
he
had expressed he was concerned that it
could spiral out of control
and
potentially
be dangerous
either
for our democracy or
the way that things were going for the
sex
when you
ballots
pressuring
filing lawsuits in certain states
where there didn't seem to be
significant evidence
and reaching out to state legislatures
about
that so pretty much the way that the
white house is handling this election
period he felt that
there could be
dangerous repercussions
in terms of precedent set for elections
for democracy
for the sixth yeah i'm just hoping that
we would concede
so ms hutchinson uh now we're going to
turn to certain information that was
available before january 4th
and what the trump administration and
the president knew about the potential
for violence before january 6.
on the screen you will see an email
received by acting deputy attorney
general donahue on january 4th from the
national security division of the
department of justice
mr donahue testified in our hearings
last week
the email identifies apparent planning
by those coming to washington on january
6 to quote occupy federal buildings and
discussions of quote invading the
capitol building here's what mr donohue
said to us
and we knew that if you have
tens of thousands of very
obsessive people showing up in
washington dc that there was potential
problems
us secret service was looking at similar
information and watching the planned
demonstrations
in fact their intelligence division sent
several emails to white house personnel
like deputy chief of staff tony ornato
and the head of the president's
protective detail robert engel
including certain materials listing
events like those on the screen
the white house continued to receive
updates about planned demonstrations
including information regarding the
proud boys organizing and planning to
attend events on january 6th
although ms hutchinson has no detailed
knowledge of any planning involving the
proud boys for january 6th she did note
this
i recall
hearing
the word oath keeper and hearing the
word proud boys
closer to the planning of the january
6th rally when mr giuliani would be
around
on january 3rd the capitol police issued
a special event assessment
in that document the capitol police
noted that the proud boys and other
groups planned to be in washington dc on
january 6
and indicated that quote unlike previous
post-election protests the targets of
the pro-trump supporters are not
necessarily the counter-protesters
as they were previously but rather
congress itself is the target on the
sixth
of course we all know now that the proud
boys showed up on january 6th
marched from the washington monument to
the capitol that day and led the riotous
mob to invade and occupy our capital
ms hutchinson i want to play you a clip
of one of our meetings
when you described a call on january 4th
that you received from national security
advisor robert o'brien
on the same topic potential violence on
january 6th
i received a call
from
robert o'brien the national security
adviser
he had asked if he could speak with mr
meadows about
potential violent words of violence that
he was hearing
that were
potentially going to happen on the hill
on january 6.
i had asked if he had connected with
tony ornato because tony and i had a
conversation with him
with mark about that topic
robert had said i'll talk to tony and
then
um
i don't know if robert ever connected
with mark about
the issue
ms hutchinson can you describe for us mr
ornato's responsibilities as deputy
chief of staff
the deputy chief of staff position at
the white house for operations is
arguably one of the most important
positions that somebody can hold
they're in charge of all security
protocol for the campus and all
presidential protectees primarily the
president and the first family but
anything that requires security for
any individual that has
presidential protection so the chief of
staff or the
national security adviser
as well as the vice president's team too
tony would oversee all of that he was
the conduit for security protocol
between white house staff and the united
states secret service
thank you and you also described a brief
meeting between mr ornato and mr meadows
on the potential for violence
the meeting was on january 4th they were
talking about the potential for violence
on january 6. let's listen to a clip of
that testimony
i remember mr ornato had
talked to him about intelligence reports
i remember mr renato coming in and
saying that we had intel reports saying
that there could potentially be violence
on this on the sixth
you also told us about reports of
violence and weapons that the secret
service were receiving on the night of
january 5th
and throughout the day on january 6th is
that correct that's correct
there are reports that police in
washington dc had arrested several
people with firearms or ammunition
following a separate pro-trump rally in
freedom plaza on the evening of january
5th are those some of the reports that
you recall hearing about
they are
of course the world now knows that the
people who attacked the capital on
january 6 had many different types of
weapons
when a president speaks the secret
service typically requires those
attending to pass through metal
detectors known as magnetometers or mags
for short
the select committee has learned that
people who willingly entered the
enclosed area for president trump's
speech
were screened so they could attend the
rally at the ellipse
they had weapons and other items that
were confiscated
pepper spray knives
brass knuckles tasers body armor gas
masks batons blunt weapons
and those were just from the people who
chose to go through the security for the
president's event on the ellipse
not the several thousand members of the
crowd who refused to go through the mags
and watched from the lawn near the
washington monument
the select committee has learned about
reports from outside the magnetometers
and has obtained police radio
transmissions
identifying individuals with firearms
including ar-15s
near the ellipse on the morning of
january 6. let's listen
within a tree
maybe a white male about six feet tall
ten build brown cowboys he's got blue
jeans and a blue jean jacket and
underneath the conclusion jacket and
we're complaining both saw
art
a group of individuals about five eight
five to
eight other individuals
two of the individuals in that group at
the base of the tree near the border
bodies or wearing green fatigue green
weapon on his right hip
how did that used in the trigger
motor one make sure ppd knows they have
an elevated threat in the trees outside
of constitutional avenue what could
adult tread on the flag
american flag face mask cowboy beats
weapon on the right right side here i've
got three men walking down the street
and fatigue was carrying 800 15 coffee
at 10 people independent
ar-15s at 14th and independence
as you saw in those emails the first
report that we showed we now know was
sent in the eight o'clock hour on
january 6th just talked about people in
the crowd wearing ballistic helmets and
body armor carrying radio equipment and
military-grade backpacks
the second report we showed you on the
screen was sent by the secret service in
the 11am hour and it addressed reports
of a man with a rifle near the ellipse
ms hutchinson in prior testimony you
described for us a meeting in the white
house around 10 a.m in the morning of
january 6th involving chief of staff
meadows and tony ronado were you in that
meeting
i was
let's listen to your testimony about
that meeting and then we'll have some
questions
i think the last time we talked you
mentioned that
some of the weapons that people had
at the rally included
flagpoles
oversized
um sticks or flagpoles
bear spray is there anything else that
you would call
hearing about the
people who would gather me what to add i
recall tony and i having a conversation
with mark probably around
10 00 am
10 15 a.m
where i remember
tony mentioning
knives
guns in the form of pistols and rifles
um bear spray body armor spears and
flagpoles
spears were one item five poles were one
item but then tony had relayed to me
something to the effect of
and these i think people are
fascinating spheres onto the ends of
flagpoles
miss hutchinson here's a clip of your
testimony regarding mr meadows response
to learning that the rally attendees
were armed that day
what was mark's reaction meadow's
reaction
to
this list of weapons that people had in
the crowd
and tony and i went in to talk to mark
that morning
mark was sitting on his couch and on his
phone which was something typical i
remember tony just got right into it i
was like sorry i want to let you know
and informed him like
this is how many people we have outside
the mags right now these are the weapons
that we're going to have it's possible
he listed more weapons off that i just
don't recall
um
and gave him a brief but
inconcise explanation but also fairly
fairly thorough
and
i remember
distinctly mark not
looking up from his phone
and i remembered
tony finishing this explanation
and it's taking a few seconds for mark
to say his name to the point where i
almost
said
mark did you hear him
um
and then bark
chimed it was like
alright anything else still looking down
on his phone
and tony looked at me and i looked at
tony and he said no sir do you have any
questions
it's like
what are you hearing
and i looked at tony and i was like so
we just told you about what was
happening down at the rallies gay i know
and then he looked up and said
have you talked to the president
and tony said yes sir he's wearing it
all right good
he asked tony if tony had informed the
president yes and tony said yes he
had so miss hutchinson is it your
understanding that mr ornato told the
president about weapons at the rally on
the morning of january 6th that's what
mr ronata relayed to me
and here's how you characterize mr
meadows general response when people
raised concerns about what could happen
on january 6th
so at the time the days leading up to
the 6th there were lots of public
reports about how things might go bad
on the sex even the potential for
violence
if i'm hearing you correctly what stands
out to you is that mr meadows did not
share those concerns or our police did
not act on those concerns
did not act on those concerns would be
accurate
but other people raised them to to him
like in this exchange you mentioned that
this tornado pulled them aside that's
correct
ms hutchinson
we're going to show now an exchange of
texts between you and deputy chief of
staff ornato
and these text messages
were
exchanged while you were at the ellipse
in one text
you write but the crowd looks good from
this vantage point as long as we get the
shot he was effing furious
and the text messages also stressed that
president trump kept mentioning the otr
and off the record movement we're going
to come back and ask you about that in a
minute but could you tell us first of
all who it is in the text who was
furious
the he in that text that i was referring
to was the president
and uh why was he furious miss
hutchinson
he was furious because he wanted the
arena that we had on the ellipse to be
maxed out at capacity for
uh all attendees
the advanced team had relayed to him
that
the mags were free-flowing everybody who
wanted to come in had already come in
but he still was angry about the extra
space and wanted more people to come in
and did you go to the rally in the
presidential motorcade i was there yes
in the morning and were you backstage uh
with the president and other members of
his staff and family i was
and you told us miss hutchinson about
particular comments that you heard while
you were in the tent area
when we were in the offstage announced
area tent behind the stage
he was very concerned about the shot
meaning the photograph that we would get
because the rally space wasn't full
um
one of the reasons which i previously
stated was because
he wanted it to be full and those people
to not feel excluded because they'd come
far to watch him at the rally
and he thought the mags were at fault
for not letting everybody in but another
leading reason and
likely the primary reason is because he
wanted it full and he was angry that we
weren't letting people through the mags
with weapons
what the secret service themed as
weapons and
our weapons
but when we were in the offstage
announced tent
i was part of a conversation
i was in the i was in the vicinity of a
conversation where i overheard the
president say something's the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing mags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here let the people in take
the effing mags away
just to be clear miss hutchinson is it
your understanding that the president
wanted to take the mags away and said
that the armed individuals were not
there to hurt him
that's a fair assessment
the issue wasn't with the amount of
space available in the official rally
area
uh
only but instead that people did not
want to have to go through the mags
let's listen to a portion of what you
told us about that
in this particular instance it wasn't
the capacity of our space it was
the mags and the people that didn't want
to come through and that's what tony had
been trying to relate to him that
morning you know it's not the issues
that we encountered on the campaign we
have enough space or
they don't want to come in right now
they they have weapons they don't want
confiscated by the secret service
and they're fine on the mall they can
see you in the mall and they want to
march straight to the capitol
from the mall
the president apparently wanted all
attendees inside the official rally
space and repeatedly said quote they're
not here to hurt me
and and just to to be clear so
um
he was told again
in that conversation or was he told to
get in that conversation that people
couldn't come through the mags because
they had weapons correct
and um
that people
and his response was to say they can
march to the capitol from
from the ellipse something to the effect
of
take the mags away they're not here to
hurt me
let them in let my people in they can
march the capitol after the rally's over
they can march from they can march from
the ellipse take the acting banks away
then they can march the capitol
as hutchinson what we saw when those
clips were playing were photos provided
by the national archives showing the
president in the offstage tent before
his speech on the ellipse you were in
some of those photos as well
and
i just want to confirm that that is when
you heard the president say the people
with weapons weren't there to hurt him
and that he wanted the secret service to
remove the magnetometers that's correct
in the photos that you displayed you're
standing towards the front of the tent
with the tvs
really close to where he would walk out
to go onto the stage
these conversations happened
two to three minutes before he took the
stage that morning
let's reflect on that for a moment
president trump was aware that a number
of the individuals in the crowd had
weapons and were wearing body armor and
here's what president trump instructed
the crowd to do
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you
we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're gonna walk
down to the capitol
[Applause]
and the crowd as we know did proceed to
the capitol it soon became apparent to
the secret service including the secret
service teams in the crowd
along with white house staff the
security at the capitol would not be
sufficient
i've had
two of these conversations with mr
ronaldo who we were at the lips
and then i had
four men on mr meadows detail with me
in between
those individuals and then a few other
bodies on the ground just see the
surface in advance
they're getting notifications through
their radios and mr porno one
conversation and called me and said make
sure the team knows that
gonna
bodies
miss hutchinson when you you said they
were having trouble stacking bodies did
you mean that law enforcement at the
capitol
needed more people to defend the capital
from the rioters
it was becoming clear to us and to the
secret service that capitol police
officers were getting overrun at the
security barricades outside of the
capitol building
and they were having short they were
short people to defend the building
against the rioters
and uh you mentioned that mr ornato was
conveying this to you because he wanted
you to tell mr meadows
uh so did you did you tell mr meadows uh
that people were getting closer to the
capitol and that capitol police was
having difficulty
after i had the conversation with mr
meadows
mr after i had the conversation with mr
oronato i went to have the discussion
with mr meadows he was in a secure
vehicle at the time making a call
so when i had gone over to the car i
went to open the door to let him know
and he had immediately shut it
i don't know who he was speaking with
it wasn't something that he regularly
did especially when i would go over to
give him information
so i was a bit taken aback
but i didn't think much of it
and thinking that i was would be able to
have the conversation with him a few
moments later
and were you able to have that
conversation a few moments later
probably about 20 to 25 minutes later
there was another period in between
where he shut the door again
and then when he finally got out of the
vehicle
he had the conversation at that point
there was a backlog of information that
he should have been made aware of
and so you opened the door to the
control car and mr meadows pulled it
shut that's correct and he did that two
times that's correct
and when you
finally were able to give mr meadows the
information
about the violence at the capitol what
was his reaction
he almost had a lack of reaction
i remember him saying
all right
something to the effect of
how much longer
does the president have left in this
speech
again uh
much of this information about the
potential for violence
was known or learned before the onset of
the violence early enough for president
trump to take steps to prevent it
he could for example have urged the
crowd at the ellipse not to march to the
capitol he could have condemned the
violence immediately once it began
or he could have taken multiple other
steps
but as we will see today and in later
hearings president trump had something
else in mind
one other question at this point ms
hutchinson were you aware of concerns
that white house counsel pat sipoloni or
eric hirschman had about the language
president trump used in his elipse
speech there were many discussions the
morning of the six about the rhetoric
of the speech that day
in my conversations with mr hirschman he
had relayed that
we would be
foolish to include language that had
been included at the president's request
which
headlines
along
to the effect of
fight for trump we're going to march the
capitol i'll be there with you fight for
me fight for what we're doing fight for
the movement
um
things about vice president at the time
too
both mr hershman and white house
counsel's office were urging the
speechwriters to not include that
language
for legal concerns and also for the
objects of what it could portray the
president wanting to do that day
and we just heard the president say that
he would be with his supporters as they
marched to the capitol
even though
he did not end up going he certainly
wanted to
um some have questioned whether
president trump genuinely planned to
come here to the capitol on january 6th
in his book mark meadows falsely wrote
that after president trump gave his
speech on january 6 he told mr meadows
he was quote speeding medic speaking
metaphorically about the walk to the
capitol
as you will see donald trump was not
speaking metaphorically
as we heard earlier rudy giuliani told
miss hutchinson that mr trump planned to
travel to the capitol on january 6.
i want to pause for just a moment
to ask you ms hutchinson to explain some
of the terminology you will hear today
we've heard you use two different terms
to describe plans for the president's
movement
the capitol or anywhere else one of
those is a scheduled movement and
another one is otr could you describe
for us what each of those mean
a scheduled presidential movement is on
his official schedule
it's notified to the press into a wide
range of staff that will be traveling
with him it's known to the public known
to the secret service and they're able
to coordinate the movement days in
advance
an off-the-record movement is confined
to the knowledge of a very very small
group of advisors and staff
typically a very small group of staff
would travel with him
mostly that are just included in the
national security package
you can pull an off to off the record
movement together in
less than an hour um
[Music]
it's a way to kind of circumvent
having
to release it to the press if that's the
goal of it or
to not have to have as many security
parameters put in place ahead of time to
make the movement happen
thank you
and let's turn back now to the
president's plans to travel to the
capitol on january 6.
we know that white house counsel pat
sipoloni was concerned about the legal
implications of such a trip and he
agreed with the secret service that it
shouldn't happen
as hutchinson did you have any
conversations with pat sipoloni about
his concerns about the president going
to the capitol on january 6th
on january 3rd mr sipoloni had
approached me knowing that mark had
raised
the prospect of going up to the capitol
on january 6.
mr sipoloni and i had a brief private
conversation where
he said to me
we need to make sure that this doesn't
happen
this would be
a legally a terrible idea for us
we have serious legal concerns if we go
up to the capitol that day and he then
urged me
to continue relaying that to mr meadows
because
it's my understanding that
mr sipoloni
thought that mr meadows was indeed
pushing this along with the president
and we understand miss hutchinson that
you also spoke to mr sipoloni on the
morning of the 6th as you were about to
go to the rally on the ellipse
and mr sippiloni said something to you
like make sure the movement to the
capital does not happen is that correct
that's correct i saw mr sipoloni right
before i walked out onto west exec that
morning
and
mr ciploni said something to the effect
of
please make sure we don't go up to the
capitol cassidy keep in touch with me
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable if we make that
movement happen
and do you remember which crimes mr
sipolini was concerned with
in the days leading up to the six we had
conversations about potentially
obstructing justice or
defrauding the electoral account
let's hear uh about some of those
concerns that you mentioned earlier
in one of your interviews with us
having a private conversation with pat
late in the afternoon of the third or
the fourth
um
that pat was concerned it would look
like we were
obstructing justice
or obstructing the electoral college
count and i apologize for probably not
being like that
very as far as my legal terms here
um
that it would have been obstructing what
was happening on capitol hill and
he was also worried that it would look
like you were inciting a riot
or encouraging a riot to erupt on the
capitol at the capitol
in fact in the days before january 6th
and on january 6 itself president trump
expressed to multiple white house aides
that he wanted to go to the capitol
after his speech here's what various
white house aides have told the
committee about the president's desire
to go to the capitol
did the president tell you this that he
wanted to speak at the capitol correct
yes
during the meeting in the dining room
did the the idea of the president
um proceeding or walking to the capitol
on the ships after his speech come up
walking to the capitol no
driving to the capitol
it came up
okay how did it come up and what was
discussed
he brought it up he said i want to go
down to the capitol
what about him marching to the capitol
on the sixth um yes
tell us about that
so
this is kind of a general thing i mean
to get into the specifics of it i
i was aware of the
desire of the president
to potentially
uh
march to the
or or accompany
the
um rally attendees to the capitol
when did you first hear about this idea
of the president accompanying rally
attendees to the capitol on the sixth
this was at the six this was during the
after he finished his remarks
when the president said that he would be
going to the capitol during his speech
on the ellipse the secret service
scrambled to find a way for him to go
we know this from witnesses
and the secret service
also from messages among staff on the
president's national security council
the nsc staff were monitoring the
situation in real time and you can see
how the situation evolved in the
following chat log that the committee
has obtained
as you can see
nsc staff believed that mogul
the president
was quote going to the capitol
and quote they are finding the best
route now
from these chats we also know the staff
learned of the attack on the capitol in
real time
when president trump left the ellipse
stage at 110 the staff knew
that rioters had invaded the inaugural
stage and capitol police were calling
for all available officers to respond
when republican leader kevin mccarthy
heard the president say he was going to
the capitol
he called you miss hutchinson
isn't that right
that's correct
and in this text message
you told tony ornato quote mccarthy just
called me too
and do you guys think you're coming to
my office
tell us about the call that day with
leader mccarthy during the president's
speech on the ellipse
i was still in the tent behind the stage
and when you're behind the stage
you can't really hear what's going on
in front of you
so when mr mccarthy called me with this
information
i answered the call and he sounded
rushed but also
frustrated and angry at me and i was
confused because i didn't know what the
president had just said
um
he then explained
the president just said he's marching to
the capitol you told me this whole week
you aren't coming up here why would you
lie to me
i said i'm i'm not lying i i wasn't
lying to you sir i
we're not going to the capitol and he
said well
he just said it on stage cassidy figure
it out
don't come up here
i said i'll i'll
i'll run the traps on this now i'll
shoot you a text i can assure you we're
not coming up to the capitol we've
already made that decision
he pressed a little bit more
believing me but i think frustrated that
the president had said that
and we ended the phone conversation
after that
i called mr ronado to reconfirm that we
weren't going to the capitol
and
which is also in our text messages
i sent mr mccarthy another text
telling him the affirmative that we were
not going up to the capitol and he
didn't respond after that
and we understand ms hutchinson that the
plans for the president to come to the
capitol
um had included discussions at some
point about uh what the president would
do
when he came up to the capitol on
january 6th
uh let's look at a clip
of one of your interviews discussing
that issue with the committee when you
were talking about a scheduled movement
did um anyone say what the president
wanted to do when he got here
no
nothing i can specifically remember i
remember
i remember hearing a few different ideas
discussed with
mark and scott perry marco rudy giuliani
i don't know
which
conversations were elevated to the
president i don't know
what he personally wanted to do when he
went up to the capitol that day
um
you know i i know that
there were discussions about him having
another speech outside of the capitol
before going in
i know that there is a conversation
about him going into the house chamber
at one point
as we've all just heard in the days
leading up to january 6th
on the day of the speech both before and
during
and after the rally speech president
trump
was pushing his staff to arrange for him
to come up here to the capitol during
the electoral vote count
let's turn now to what happened in the
president's vehicle
when the secret service told him he
would not go into the capitol
after his speech
first here is the president's motorcade
leaving the ellipse after his speech on
january 6th
ms hutchinson
when you returned to the white house in
the motorcade after the president's
speech where did you go
when i returned to the white house i
walked upstairs towards the chief of
staff's office and i noticed mr renato
lingering outside of the office once we
had made eye contact he quickly waved me
to go into his office which was just
across the hall from mine
when i went in he shut the door i
noticed bobby engel who's the head of mr
trump's security detail sitting in a
chair just looking somewhat
discombobulated a little lost
um
i looked at tony and he had said
did you i think hear what happened in
the beast
he said no tony i just got back
what happened
tony proceeded to tell me that
when the president got in the beast he
was under the impression from mr meadows
that the off the record movement to the
capitol was still possible and likely to
happen but that bobby had more
information
so once the president had
gotten into the vehicle with bobby
he thought that they were going up to
the capitol and when bobby had relayed
to him
we're not we don't have the assets to do
it it's not secure
we're going back to the west wing
the president had
very strong
very angry response to that
um
[Music]
tony described him as being irate
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
taking me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and
when mr ronaldo had recounted the story
to me he had motioned towards his
clavicles
and was mr engel
in the room as mr ornato told you this
story he was
did mr engel
correct or disagree with any part of the
story from mr ornato mr engel did not
correct or disagree with any part of the
story
did mr engel or mr ornato ever after
that tell you that what mr ornato had
just said was untrue
neither mr ornato nor mr engel told me
ever that it was untrue
and despite this altercation this
physical altercation
during the ride back to the white house
president trump
still demanded to go to the capitol
here's what kaylee mcenany the white
house press secretary at the time wrote
in her personal notes and told the
committee about president trump's desire
to go to the capitol
after returning to the white house
when you wrote the post wanted to walk
to the capitol
was that based solely on what the
president said during his speech or
anything that he or anybody else said
afterwards
so to the best of my recollection i
believe when we got back to the white
house he said he wanted to physically
walk
with the marchers and according to my
notes he then said uh
you'd be fine with just writing the
beast but that's my recollection he
wanted to be
a part of the march in some fashion
okay and just for the record the beast
refers to the presidential limousine
yes
president trump did not go to the
capitol that day
we understand that he blamed mark
meadows for that
so prior to leaving the rally site
when he got off the stage
and everybody was making the movement
back to the motorcade i had overheard mr
meadows say to him then as i had prior
to mr trump taking the stage that
morning
um
that he was still working on
getting an off the record movement to
the capitol so mr trump took the stage
he was under the impression
by mr meadows that
it was still possible so when he got off
the stage
i had released mr meadows that i had
another conversation with tony the
movement was still not possible
mr meadow said okay
and then as they proceeded to go to the
motorcade
um
and
mr meadows had reiterated we're going to
work on sir talks bobby bobby has more
information
mark got into his vehicle to my
understanding trump got into the beast
and
after we'd all arrived back at the white
house
later in the day
it had been relayed to me by a mark that
the president wasn't happy that bobby
didn't pull it off for him and that mark
didn't work hard enough to get the
movement on the books
the physical altercation that ms
hutchinson described in the presidential
vehicle was not the first time that the
president
had become very angry about issues
relating to the election
on december 1 2020 attorney general barr
said in an interview that the department
of justice had not not found evidence of
widespread election fraud sufficient to
change the outcome of the election
ms hutchinson how did the president
react to hearing that news
around the time that i understand
the ap article went live
i remember hearing noise coming from
down the hallway so i poked my head out
of the office i saw the valet walking
towards our office he had said
get the chief down to the dining room
the president wants him
so mark went down to the dining room
came back to the office a few minutes
later
after mark had returned i left the
office and went down to the dining room
and i noticed that the doors propped
open and the valet was inside the dining
room changing the tablecloth off of the
dining room table
he motioned for me to come in
and then pointed towards the front of
the room near the fireplace mantle on
the tv where
i first noticed there was ketchup
dripping down the wall
and there's a shattered porcelain plate
on the floor
the valet had articulated that the
president
was
extremely angry at the attorney
general's ap interview
and had thrown his lunch against the
wall
um
which was causing them to have to clean
up so i grabbed a towel and started
wiping the catch up off the wall to help
the valet out
um
and he said something to the effect of
he's really ticked off about this
i would stay clear of him for right now
he's really really ticked off about this
right now
and miss hutchinson
was this the only instance that you are
aware of where the president
threw dishes
it's not
and are there other instances in the
dining room that you recall where he
expressed his anger
there were there were several times
throughout my tenure with the chief of
staff that i was aware
of him either throwing dishes or
flipping the tablecloth
um
to let all the contents of the table go
onto the floor and
likely break or
go everywhere
and miss hutchinson attorney general
barr
described to the committee the
president's
angry reaction when he finally met with
president trump
let's listen
and uh i said look i i
know that you're dissatisfied with me
and i'm glad to offer my resignation and
he pounded the table very hard everyone
sort of jumped and he said accept me
mr chairman i reserve
gentlewoman reserves the chair requests
those in the hearing room to remain
seated
until the capitol police have escorted
our witness from the room
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today
the chair declares the committee in
recess for a period of approximately 10
minutes
so there you have it the hearing with uh
huge bombshells
here as we
watch the witness cassidy hutchinson
leave the room
with security in tow
benny thompson does not
does not look thrilled about the
evidence that has been presented because
it was a threat to our democracy i want
to bring in our panel uh you hear
clapping in the room now i want to bring
in our panel real quick because we don't
have a lot of time i want to give
everyone a chance uh so give me just a
minute as i bring in everyone here um we
have a big panel here
everybody holy
actual [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
yes um so i wanna i wanna go to uh let's
start at the bottom at rachel
bittikoffer rachel uh if you wanna meet
your mic and tell us exactly what you
what you saw there um again let's let's
keep it short so everyone has a chance
to speak but go ahead
yeah i'll keep it real short whoo
and i'm very proud of cassidy hutchinson
for coming and telling us the truth
today that i think we're getting the
actual whole truth and nothing but the
truth from her and damn look at this
like trump is a physical
abuser and that's that's just a crazy
spin that i didn't see coming somebody
else go
go ahead go ahead david if you want
yes this reminds me uh and again going
back in in memory to john dean
her her precision the fact that she
remembers every detail and can do it
without looking at notes she can tell
you where she was that the door was
pulled shut when and they'll be very
interesting to find out who
uh meadows was talking to that she
couldn't hear
while trump was still speaking but the
precision of her testimony reminded me
of john dean
and let's be clear john dean was the
linchpin to bringing down richard nixon
this was an important incredible day
uh karen agnivolo let's go to you um i
know you probably have a lot of notes
there um for what you want to say but
give us give us in a quick synopsis what
you thought of some of this testimony uh
the president united states being i
don't know the baby in chief this is um
this is crazy stuff
yeah so
i still don't understand so i still
don't understand what's new because so
much of what she testified to was also
they would keep going back and forth
between the clips and what was the
emergency makes me wonder was this
planned you know and they sort of so she
couldn't get threat threatened before
but you know a lot of this already had
come out in the clips and was taped but
the real bombshell that i thought was
just sort of how violent the president
is and the fact that he tried to grab
the wheel of his of the the beast and
which is such a weird word anyway for a
car um but they tried to grab the wheel
that he tried to attack
um angle the fact that he
you know throws dishes and and threw a
temperature interim and tried to you
know throw the throat yeah exactly hi
ben you know the fact that he kind of
grabbed the the tablecloth and you know
just to show that he's sort of a violent
dude and
um he's kind of an out of control guy
you know like like i'm sure he's
horrified to know now that the whole
world knows that he's out of control and
loses control of his crazy baby emotions
so you know so i thought that that was
the big bombshell i think the circ that
she basically threw mark meadows and
rudy giuliani and donald trump under the
bus i i won't be surprised to see those
three people prosecuted i'll i'll turn
it over to to ben micellas
uh ben let's let's go to you i've seen
my time i seized my time i have my
ketchup karen most of that was not known
to me i mean there was in my view
revelation after revelation there i mean
she took us right in the heart of what
was going on on january 6th and the
biggest piece of it was was that
trump viewed himself like a napoleon
conquering and he wanted to
go into the capitol building with the
insurrectionist who he wanted to be
armed with ar-15s and he wanted to
literally you know and as i think what
he's saying that good without hanging
you know vice president pence and
everything his plan in his own sick mind
was to go to the chamber and like
declare himself dictator i mean that's
what we heard today um you know let me
ask you a question
can i ask you a question sorry tony
i don't take your role but i have a
question for ben i agree most of this
wasn't known to any of us right but it
was known to the committee it was on
tape what was the emergency that
happened in the last 24 hours that they
needed to have this live versus do you
think it was just she changed her mind
and was willing to come in live do you
think she had a change of heart that's
my question is so much of what she had
her notes in her notebook and she was
very methodical but a lot of it was was
taped in in the bag for the hearing
people what was it that caused them to
call this hearing an emergency and
present this live that that's my
question that i'd love to hear your take
ben
my take is is that we're in like
halftime right now right so
we've heard some bombshells in halftime
but we don't know you know where the
hearing is going to go in a little bit
we know that there's kind of documentary
evidence supporting it but i would say
we're in recess we're going to go back
and
i'm okay with how they wanted to frame
it they want to call it an emergency
unemerging call whatever the hell you
want it but we exposed donald trump
today and then let's see what happens in
the next you know when we come back from
recess i would just say i don't have a i
don't have a concrete answer for karen
but i've heard some speculation that
there may be this may have been a
balancing act with things that are going
on at the doj
um wanting to either preempt or get this
this testimony out from prior to
something happening at the doj i have no
solid um you know information but that's
speculation that i've heard i just
wanted to add like i mean this
these violent outbursts from donald
trump hearing them in real time like
this i mean it's it is it's just floors
you but let us not forget this is a man
who had credible multiple credible
allegations of rape going back decades
so
we know this is these are his
proclivities and for god's sakes let us
finally hold him accountable this time
uh i want to go to uh the texas paul uh
texas paul what did you think of some of
the bombshells there i mean i don't
think it's surprising that donald trump
is a little whiny baby but the the thing
that struck me and speak on this if you
would
he really he really like ben said
napoleon um complex here he thought he
was gonna go there he could do whatever
he want even grab a steering wheel and
grab someone by the throat
to get physically violent in that moment
um because he's so pissed off that
they're not letting him be the dictator
he wants to be what did you what do you
think of that paul exactly ben beat me
to it that was exactly my first thought
was that this was his plan he knew these
people were armed he knew they were
armed with ar-15s he knew they were
armed with with with handguns he was
going to march them down to the capitol
he was going to walk into the middle of
the capitol and declare himself king
that's exactly what he intended to do
that day and it was being taken away
from him because he could not be there
he saw people responding to this
situation he saw that's why he would not
call it off
because he had every intention of
walking down there and declaring himself
king the other thing that just
completely
just
i have been dying to find out who was
talking to the oath keepers and the
proud boys and and and
facilitating the violence and the fact
that rudy giuliani knew on the second
he knew on that meeting he told he told
i you know i jotted it down here he he
told he told cassidy hutchinson on the
second the proud boys and the oath
keepers were gonna be there and and who
was armed
you know
we
oh
this is i mean this is it this this is
it i believe you're absolutely right the
the reason that this was i thought maybe
it was death threats was why that they
had to bump this up so much that she was
getting nervous because of death threats
you know i believe i believe jessica's
absolutely right the you know we've seen
fbi agents moving over the last few days
like what happened with eastman coming
out of the restaurant i believe that
that they are they are moving and they
don't have the patience to wait for the
showmanship anymore so that i think that
they agreed to get this out there today
get it over with and you watch there
will be fbi agents all
over the damn place over the next few
days i think catching up people's
electronic devices but i am so god damn
man i just
can you believe that arrogant son of a
[ __ ] i mean attacked his own security
throwing dishes and [ __ ] like that
that's not a president well that's not
he's out of control he's out of control
what i tell you
ketchup and broken glass
well i'll tell you i'll tell you that
that um i'm not surprised by it actually
i'm i'm actually i was surprised to hear
it come out of someone's mouth finally
under oath in front of the world but i'm
not surprised that that was the
statement uh gabe does so many videos
and he actually predicts things that he
doesn't even know he predicts because
these people are so easily predicted he
actually had a video that he put out
months and months and months ago and it
had cassidy hutchinson in it
inadvertently even didn't even know it
didn't even know it but but these people
are so easy to predict because they're
so
unpredictably unpredictable if you want
to put it that way donald trump is a
whiny little [ __ ] he's been that way
for a long long long time he will
continue to be that way even if he is in
an orange jumpsuit and leg irons he will
continue to be a whiny little [ __ ] gabe
what do you think about some of the
stuff we i i know you're not surprised i
mean no yeah i mean yeah none of this is
surprising but i mean like the key
detail is kind of painting the picture
of what happened that day behind the
scenes were like okay what we always
were suspecting actually ended up be
true i mean like the fact that he's
throwing dishes in its ketchup we know
he was eating fast food we know that
after after the election that people in
the white house had to clear out the
odor of flatulence he was farting
everywhere from eating ben he's binging
eating fast food
that's the kind of guy he's sitting in
the goddamn car having a tantrum because
he wants to go to disney world trying to
take control from his parents being the
secret service and then they say no get
back in the seat we're going back home
and then he starts trying to choke out
the parent which is the secret service
like what world do we live in where the
sitting president of the united states
begins to choke out the person that's
there to protect him
like what what is happening what what
what alternative universe are we in you
can't even write this stuff
what's happening is he wanted to be king
and they were not letting him do it
exactly he knows if he i guarantee you
if donald trump had made his way down to
the capitol with all these armed sons
and [ __ ] and he said it himself
they're not here to hurt me take the
magnetometers away he knew
about this plan very very important
observation they're not there to hurt me
well then who are they there to hurt
right and he knew exactly what it was a
couple of things gabe you got to connect
up something you just said
there's flatulence
why do you think they call it the beast
get into that thing with him of course
it's the beast and by the way i think we
learned something new i could be wrong
this is the first time i've heard his
secret service code name is mogul
i've heard i've heard that before maybe
you know maybe my code name for him
grandpa poopypants now that gabe has
exposed him as a flatulence
maybe that would be more vogel was was a
revelation but the thing that i if if i
can suggest one
fact we know
is that recently
uh cassidy hutchinson changed council
she changed council from having uh a
trump friendly council to jodi hunt who
was chief staff to jeff sessions
jody hunt was the guy in the oval office
who bore witness to trump's reaction
when he was told that mueller had been
appointed yep i believe the exact quote
is jesus i'm [ __ ]
is now our hunting
seriously on the point you were making
gain this out trump makes it to the
capitol
trump gets into the chamber
game this out what happens because if
they don't finish their work on january
6th we know what starts to happen with
the clock and they had what till the
11th or something before they went to
the boat
it goes to the house after that if they
can't break you're 70 right
but what happens gain this up trump
makes it down i mean let's let's live in
that reality trump reality
hang on a second hang on a second i have
some i have some breaking news here um
donald trump is truthing from his two
central account um here here is the
words that he's he's tweeting uh gabe
can you can you see if you can put
together a graphic so we can pull that
up real quick um we're watching as the
committee's coming back in but i want to
i want to get to this i hardly know who
this person cassie hutchin is other than
i heard very negative things about her a
total phony and leaker and when she
requested to go for certain others it's
hard to read his writing here of the
team to florida after my hamming served
a full term in office um the committee
is uh working their way back into the
room i apologize to the panel to cut you
guys off but there is breaking news um
donald trump uh gabe maybe you can tweet
that out or um from our account and so
everyone can see that we're going to go
back to the
we're going to go back to the hearing
here
in just a second um i got to get the
volume point thank you everybody for
joining us
what miss hutchinson saw and heard in
the white house
during the violent attack on the capitol
on january 6th
let's discuss certain communications
white house chief of staff mark meadows
had on january 5th
president trump's associate
roger stone attended rallies during the
afternoon and the evening of january 5th
in washington dc
on january 5th and 6th
mr stone was photographed with multiple
members of the oath keepers who were
allegedly serving as his security detail
as we now know
multiple members of that organization
have been charged with or pled guilty to
crimes associated with january 6th
mr stone has invoked his fifth amendment
privilege against self-incrimination
before this committee
general michael flynn has also taken the
fifth before this committee
mr stone previously had been convicted
of other federal crimes
unrelated to january 6th
general flynn had pleaded guilty to a
felony charge also predating and
unrelated to january 6th
president trump pardoned general flynn
just weeks after the presidential
election
and in july of 2020 he commuted the
sentence roger stone was to serve
the night before january 6th president
trump instructed his chief of staff mark
meadows to contact both roger stone
and michael flynn regarding what would
play out the next day
miss hutchinson is it your understanding
that president trump asked mark meadows
to speak with roger stone and general
flynn on january 5th
that's correct that is my understanding
and ms hutchinson is it your
understanding that mr meadows called mr
stone on the fifth
i'm under the impression that mr meadows
did complete both a call to
mr stone and general flynn the evening
of the fifth
and do you know what they talked about
that evening ms hutchinson i'm not sure
is it your understanding that mr
giuliani mr eastman and others had set
up what has been called quote a war room
at the willard hotel on the night of the
fifth
i was aware of that the night of the
fifth
and do you know if mr meadows ever
intended to go to the willard hotel on
the night of the fifth
mr meadows had a conversation with me
where he wanted me to work with secret
service on a movement from the white
house to the ballard hotel so he could
attend the meeting
or meetings with mr giuliani and his
associates in the war room
and what was your view as to whether or
not mr meadows should go to the willard
that night
i had made it clear to mr meadows that
i didn't believe it was a smart idea for
him to go to the willard hotel that
night
i wasn't sure everything that was going
on at the willard hotel although i knew
enough about what
mr giuliani and his associates were
pushing during this period
i didn't think that it was something
appropriate for the white house chief of
staff to attend or to consider
involvement in
i made that clear to mr meadows
throughout the afternoon he mentioned a
few more times going up
to the willard hotel that evening
and then eventually dropped the subject
the night of
the 5th and said that he would dial in
instead
so general flynn has
appeared before this committee
and when he appeared before our
committee he took the fifth
let's briefly view a clip
of general mike flynn taking the fifth
amendment
general flynn do you believe the
violence on january 6 was justified
yes
did you repeat the question please
yes general flynn do you believe the
violence on january 6 was
justified is that
can i get a clarification is that a
moral question
i'm asking
both
do you believe the violence on january 6
was justified morally
you believe the violence on january 6
was justified legally
general flynn do you believe in the
peaceful transition of power in the
united states of america
let's move on now to january 6th and the
conduct of donald trump and mark meadows
during the attack on the capitol
as such and said i'd like now for us to
listen to a description
your description of what transpired in
the west wing during the attack
for context in this clip you describe
the time frame starting at about 2 p.m
so i remember
marking alone in his office for
quite some time and you know
i know we've spoken about ben williamson
going in at one point and i don't
personally remember ben going and i
don't doubt that he had gone in
um
but i remember him being alone in his
office for most of the afternoon around
two o'clock to 205
around two o'clock to 205
you know we were watching the tv and i
could see that the riders were getting
closer and closer to the capitol
mark still hadn't popped out of his
office or said anything about it so
that's when i went into his office i saw
that he was sitting on his couch
on a cell phone
same as the morning where he was just
kind of scrolling and typing
i said
hey are you watching the tv chief
his tv was small
you can see it but i didn't know if he
was really paying attention
watching the tv chief he's like
yeah
the writers are getting really close so
we talked to the president he said
no he wants to be alone right now
still looking at his phone
so i start to get frustrated because
i sort of felt like i was watching
it's just not a great comparison but a
bad car accident that's about to happen
where
you can't stop it but
you want to be able to do something
and i just remember i remember thinking
in that moment
mark needs to snap out of this and i
don't know how to snap him out of this
but he he needs to care
and i just remember i blurted out i said
martinez jim's out right now
and he looked up at me at that point
said jim i said
marcus he was on the floor a little
while ago giving a floor speech did you
listen
he said yeah it was really good did you
like it and i said yeah
do you know where he's at right now
he said no i haven't heard from him
you might want to check in with him
remember pointing at the tv and if the
writers are getting close
they might get in
and he looked at me and said
something to be effective
all right i'll give him a call
not long after the rioters broke into
the capitol
you described what happened with white
house counsel pat sipoloni
no more than a minute
a minute and a half later i see past the
balloon barreling down the hallway
towards our office
and
rushed right in looked at me
said is mark in his office i said yes
he just looked at me and started shaking
his head and he went over open
marks off the store
stood there with the door propped open
and said something to the mark is still
sitting on his phone i remember glancing
and he's still sitting on his phone
and i remember pat saying to him
something to the effect of
the writers have gotten to the capitol
mark we need to go down and see the
president now
and mark looked up at it and said he
doesn't want to do anything bad
and had said something to the effect of
and very clearly
had
said this to mark something to the
effect of
mark something needs to be done or
people are going to die and the blood's
going to be on your effing hands this is
getting out of control i'm going down
there and at that point mark stood up
from his palace both of his phones in
his hand he had his glasses on still
he walked out with pat
he put both of his phones on my desk and
said let me know if jim calls
and they walked out and went down to the
dining room
a few minutes later representative
jordan called back
a couple minutes later so likely around
between 2 15
and 2 25 i know the tweet went out at 2
24 i don't remember if i was
there when the tweet went out or if it
happened right afterwards but
jim had called i answered the phone
said one second he knew it was i guess
he knew and i introduced myself but i
don't remember if he called my cell
phone if he had called one of marks um
but i also remembered one second mark's
on the home i'm gonna go hand the phones
and he said okay
so i went down i asked the ballet if
mark was in the dining room
valerie said yes i opened the door to
the dining room
briefly stepped in
to get mark's attention
showed him the phone like flipped the
phone his way so he could see it said
jim jordan
he had stepped to where i was standing
there holding the door open
took the phone talking to jim with the
door still propped open
so i took a few steps back so i probably
was
two feet from mark he was standing in
the doorway going to the oval office
dining room
they had a brief conversation and
in the crossfires you know i heard
briefly like what they were talking
about but in the background i had heard
conversations in the oval dining room
at that point
talking about the hang mike pence chance
that clip ended ms hutchinson with you
recalling you heard the president mr
meadows and the white house council
discussing the hang mike pence chance
and then you described for us what
happened next
wasn't until
mark hung up the phone
handed it back to me i went back to my
desk
a couple minutes
later him and pat came back possibly
eric hershman too i'm pretty sure eric
person was there
but i'm i'm confident it was pot that
was there
um
i remember pat saying something to the
effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling
for the vice president's the acting hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
to which pet said something
this is acting crazy
we need to be doing something more
briefly stepped into
mark's office and when mark had said
something the markets have said
something to the effect of he doesn't
think they're doing anything wrong
knowing what i had heard
briefly in the dining room
coupled with pot discussing the hang
mike pence chance
in the lobby of our office and then mark
spawns i understood there
to be the riders in the capital that
were
chanting
for the vice president to be hung
let me pause here on this point
as rioters chanted hang mike pence
the president of the united states
donald trump
said that quote mike deserves it
and that those rioters were not doing
anything wrong
this is a sentiment that he has
expressed at other times as well in an
interview
with abc news correspondent jonathan
carl
president trump was asked
about the supporters chanting hang mike
pence last year
instead of condemning them the former
president defended them
because
it's common sense
it's common sense
that
you're supposed to protect how can you
if you know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
president trump's view that the rioters
were not doing anything wrong
and that quote mike deserved it
helps us to understand why the president
did not ask the rioters to leave the
capitol for multiple hours
in fact he put this tweet out at 2 24 pm
miss hutchinson do you recall
seeing this tweet in which the president
said the vice president did not have the
courage to do what needed to be done
thank you
mitch hutchinson what was your reaction
when you saw this tweet
as a staffer that works
to always represent the administration
to the best of my ability
and to showcase the good things that he
had done for the country
i remember feeling frustrated
disappointed
and
really it felt personal i it was really
sad
as an american
i was disgusted
it was
unpatriotic it was
un-american we were watching
the capitol building get defaced over a
lie
and it was something that was really
hard
in that moment to digest knowing what
i'd been hearing
down the hall
and the conversations that were
happening
seeing that tweet come up and knowing
what was happening on the hill
and it's something that i
it's still i still struggle to work
through
the emotions of that
the sentence that we have also spoken to
multiple other white house staff about
their reaction to donald trump's 224
tweet
condemning mike pence for not having the
courage
to refuse to count electoral votes an
act that would have been illegal matthew
pottinger
a former marine intelligence officer
who served in the white house for four
years including including as deputy
national security advisor
was in the vicinity of the oval office
at various points throughout the day
when he saw that tweet he immediately
decided to resign his position
let's watch him describe his reaction to
the president's tweet
one of my staff brought me a printout
uh of a
tweet
by the president
and the tweet uh said something to the
fact that uh mike pence the vice
president didn't have the courage
um
to do what he what should have been done
um i uh
i read that tweet
uh and
made a decision
at that moment to resign
that's where i knew that i was leaving
that day
once i read that tweet
ultimately
members of the white house staff sarah
matthews cabinet members secretary chao
and secretary devos resigned as well
here is secretary devos's resignation
letter
as you can see in resigning on january 6
secretary devos said to the president
there's no mistaking the impact your
rhetoric had on the situation and it is
the inflection point for me
let's also look at secretary chao's
resignation statement
when secretary chao resigned she spoke
of the january 6 attack
and she said quote as i am sure is the
case with many of you
this has deeply troubled me in a way i
simply cannot set aside
miss hutchinson in our prior interviews
we've asked you about what the
president's advisors were urging him to
do during the attack
you've described roughly three different
camps of thought inside the white house
that day can you tell us about those
there was a group of individuals that
were strongly urging him to take
immediate and swift action
i would classify the white house
counsel's office mr hirschman miss
ivanka trump
in that category of
really working
to get him to take action and pleading
with him to take action
there was a more neutral group
where
advisors were trying to toe the line
knowing that mr trump didn't necessarily
want to take immediate action
and condemn the riots
um but knowing something needed to be
done
um and then there was the last group
which was
deflect and blame
let's blame it but these aren't our
people
it's my understanding that
mr meadows was in
the deflect and blame category but he
did end up taking a more neutral route
knowing that there were several advisers
in
the president's circle urging him to
take
more action um
which i think was reflected in the
rhetoric released later that day in the
videos
you told us that the white house
counsel's office was in the camp
encouraging the president
to tell the writers to stop the attack
and to leave the capital let's listen
white house counsel's office wanted
there to be a strong statement out to
condemn the rioters i'm confident in
that
now let's look at just one example of
what some senior advisors to the
president were urging
mrs hutchinson could you look at the
exhibit that we're showing on the screen
now
have you seen this note before
that's a note that i wrote at the
direction of the chief of staff on
january 6 likely around 3 o'clock
and it's written on a chief of staff
note card but that's your handwriting ms
hutchinson that's my handwriting
and why did you write this note
the chief of staff was in a meeting with
eric hirschman and potentially mr
philbin and they had
rushed out of the office fairly quickly
mark had handed me the note card with
one of his pens
and sort of dictating a statement for
the president to potentially put out
and
no i'm sorry go ahead that's okay uh
there are two phrases on there one
illegal and then one without proper
authority the illegal phrase was the one
that mr meadows had dictated to me
mr hershman had chimed in
and said also put without legal
authority
there should have been a slash between
the two phrases there's an ore if the
president had opted to put one of those
statements out
evidently he didn't later that afternoon
mark came back from the oval dining room
and put the palm card on my desk
with illegally crossed out but said we
didn't need to take further action on
that statement
so um to your knowledge this statement
was never issued it was to my knowledge
it was never issued
and ms henderson did you understand that
ivanka trump wanted her father to send
people home
that's my understanding yes let's play a
clip of you addressing that issue
i remember her saying
at various points no she wants
him she wanted her dad to send them home
she wanted her dad to
tell them to go home peacefully and she
wanted to include
language that he necessarily wasn't on
board with at the time
you will hear more about this at our
later hearings but we have evidence of
many others imploring donald trump and
mark meadows to take action
here is some of that evidence text
messages sent to mark meadows during the
attack
this is a text message at 232 from laura
ingram
hey mark the president needs to tell
people in the capitol to go home
in the next message this is hurting all
of us
and then he's destroying his legacy and
playing into every stereotype we lose
all credibility against the blm antifa
crowd if things go south
the president's son don jr also urgently
contacted mark meadows at 2 53 he wrote
he's got to condemn this [ __ ] asap the
capital police tweet is not enough
as you will see these are just two of
the numerous examples of trump
supporters and allies urging the
president to tell his supporters to
leave the capitol
it would not have been hard for the
president to simply walk down to the
briefing room
a few feet down the hall from the oval
office
as norah o'donnell noted during an
interview with house republican leader
kevin mccarthy
where leader mccarthy said he believed
the attack was un-american
i want to quickly bring in kevin
mccarthy the house minority leader
leader mccarthy
do you condemn this violence
i completely condemn the violence in the
capital what we're currently watching
unfold is un-american
i am i'm disappointed i'm sad this is
not what our country should look like
this is not who we are this is not the
first amendment this has to stop and
this has to stop now
leader mccarthy the president united
states has a briefing room steps from
the oval office it is the cameras are
hot 24 7 as you know why hasn't he
walked down and said that now
i i convey to the president what i think
is best to do and i'm hopeful the
president will do it
republican house member mike gallagher
also
implored the president to call off the
attack
mr president
you have got to stop this you are the
only person who can call this
off
call it off
the election is over
call it off
this is bigger than you it's bigger than
any member of congress is about the
united states of america
which is more important than any
politician
call it off
it's over
despite the fact that many people close
to donald trump were urging him to send
people home
he did not do so until later
much later
at 4 17 p.m donald trump finally told
the rioters to go home
and that he loved them
here's a portion of the video president
trump recorded from the white house
we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil
i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
but as we will show in even greater
detail in future hearings
donald trump was reluctant to put this
message out and he still could not bring
himself to condemn the attack
miss hutchinson has told us that too
one that he put out at 4 17
um
i'm sure you've discussed it and just to
elaborate if i hadn't already at that
point
i recall him
being reluctant to film the video on the
six i was not involved in
any of the logistics or the planning for
that video i just remember seeing the
video go out
and feeling a little shocked after it
went out
on the evening of january 6th and the
day after the president's family and his
senior staff and others tried to
encourage the president to condemn the
violence and commit to the peaceful
transition of power
at 3 31 pm on january 6 sean hannity of
fox news texted mark
meadows mr hannity said quote can he
make a statement i saw the tweet
ask people to leave the capitol
later that evening mr hannity sent
another text message to mark meadows
this time he shared a link to a tweet
that tweet reported that president
trump's cabinet secretaries were
considering invoking the 25th amendment
to remove president trump from office
as you can see on the screen
the 25th amendment to the constitution
creates a process for the transition of
power if a president is unfit or unable
to serve
25th amendment has never been used to
remove a president
but the committee has learned that after
the attack on the u.s capitol
this was being discussed by members of
president trump's cabinet
as a way of stripping the full power of
the presidency from donald trump
president trump's supporters were
worried
in addition to the tweet that he sent
mark meadows after the attack
sean hannity apparently spoke with
president trump and warned him about
what could happen
we understand that this text message
that sean hannity sent to kaylee
mcinning on january 7th shows what mr
hannity said to the president first
no more stolen election talk
second
impeachment and 25th amendment are real
many people will quit
ms hutchinson you told us that you were
hearing about discussions related to the
25th amendment here's part of what you
said
mr pompeo reached out to have the
conversation with mr meadows in case he
hadn't heard the
discussions amongst cabinet secretaries
and what i understand it was more of a
this is what i'm hearing
i want you to be aware of it
but i also think it's worth putting on
your radar because you are the chief of
staff you're technically the boss of all
the cabinet secretaries and
you know if
conversations progress you should
be better to take action on this like
i'm concerned for
you and your positioning with this
please ask me if you have any questions
or like i wouldn't be helpful with you
at all
inside the white house the president's
advisors including members of his family
wanted him to deliver a speech to the
country
deputy white house counsel pat philbin
prepared the first draft of what would
be the president's remarks on national
healing
delivered by a pre-taped video on
january 7th
when he arrived at the white house on
the 7th mr philbin believed that more
needed to be said
so he sat down and started writing
he shared the draft with pat sipoloni
who also believed the president needed
to say more
mr sipoloni agreed with the content as
did eric hirschman who reviewed the
draft
the committee has learned that the
president did not agree with the
substance as drafted and resisted giving
a speech at all
miss hutchinson do you recall
discussions about the president's speech
on january 7th
i do
let's listen ms hutchison to what you
told us about that and about the process
of crafting those remarks
uh i learned from a conversation with
mark and
over here between him and white house
counsel and
um
eric hirschman as well that
trump didn't necessarily think he needed
to do
anything more on the seventh than what
he had
already done
on the 6th
when he was
convinced to put out a video on the 7th
he i understand that he had
a lot of opinions about what the context
of that announcement were to entail um i
had original drafts of the speech where
there were several lines that didn't
make it in there about
prosecuting the rioters or calling them
violent
he didn't want that in there he wanted
to put him in it he wanted to
have potentially pardon them
um
it was just with the increased emphasis
of
his mindset at the time which was he
didn't think they did anything wrong
the people who did something wrong that
day or the person who did something
wrong that day was like by not standing
with him
but the president's advisers urged him
to give the speech
who convinced him to do
the video on the seven i'm not sure who
convinced him if it was a group of
people that convinced
him who is in the group that you're
aware of that i love
mark ivanka
jared kushner
um
eric hershman pasaboloni
pat feldman
those are people that i'm aware of
do you know why that group of people
thought it was necessary for him to
release a statement
i believe kelly mcinerney as well
um
from what i understood at the time
and from what the reports were coming in
there's a
large concern of
the 25th amendment potentially being
invoked and there were concerns about
what would happen in the senate
if it was if the 25th was invoked
so the primary reason that i had heard
other than you know
we did not do enough on the six we need
to get a stronger message out there and
condemn this this will be your legacy
the secondary reason to that was
think about what might happen in the
final 15 days of your presidency if we
don't
do this there's already talked about
invoking the 25th amendment you need
this as cover
the president ultimately delivered the
remarks
unlike many of his other speeches he did
not ad-lib much
he recited them
without significant alteration except
one
even then
on january 7 2021
the day after the attack on the u.s
capitol the president still could not
bring himself to say quote that this
election is now
over
one other point about the speech ms
hutchinson did you hear that mr trump at
one point wanted to add language about
pardoning those who took part in the
january 6 riot
i did hear that and i understand that mr
that mr meadows was encouraging that
language as well
thank you and here's what you told us
previously about that
you said he was instructed not to
include it who was instructing him not
to include language about the part in
that january 7th i understood from white
house counsel's office coming into our
office that morning that they didn't
think that it was a good idea to include
that in speech that being passed ability
that's correct
and their encouragement
miss hutchinson
did rudy giuliani ever suggest that he
was interested in receiving a
presidential pardon related to january
6th
he did
ms hutchison
did white house chief of staff mark
meadows ever indicate that he was
interested in receiving a presidential
pardon related to january 6.
mr meadows did seek that pardon yes
ma'am
thank you miss hutchinson mr chairman i
yield back
i want to thank our witness for joining
us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
witness
and we ask that you respond
expeditiously in writing to those
questions
without objections members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for the witness
without objection the chair recognized
the vice chair for a closing statement
thank you very much mr chairman
i want to begin by thanking ms
hutchinson for her testimony today we
are all in her debt
our nation is preserved by those who
abide by their oaths to our constitution
our nation is preserved by those who
know the fundamental difference between
right and wrong
and i want all americans to know that
what ms hutchinson has done today is not
easy
the easy course is to hide from the
spotlight to refuse to come forward
to attempt to downplay or deny what
happened
that brings me to a different topic
while our committee has seen many
witnesses
including many republicans
testify fully and forthrightly
this has not been true of every witness
and we have received evidence
of one particular practice that raises
significant concern
our committee commonly asks witnesses
connected to mr trump's administration
or campaign
whether they've been contacted by any of
their former colleagues or anyone else
who attempted to influence or impact
their testimony
without identifying any of the
individuals involved let me show you a
couple of samples of answers we received
to this question
first
here's how one witness described phone
calls from people interested in that
witness's testimony
quote what they said to me is as long as
i continue to be a team player
they know i'm on the right team i'm
doing the right thing
i'm protecting who i need to protect
you know i'll continue to stay in good
graces in trump world
and they have reminded me a couple of
times
that trump does read transcripts
and just keep that in mind as i proceed
through my interviews with the committee
here's another sample in a different
context this is a call received by one
of our witnesses
quote a person let me know you have your
deposition tomorrow
he wants me to let you know he's
thinking about you he knows you're loyal
and you're going to do the right thing
when you go in for your deposition
i think most americans know that
attempting to influence witnesses to
testify and truthfully
presents very serious concerns
we will be discussing these issues as a
committee
carefully considering our next steps
mr chairman thank you i yield back
the woman yields back ms hutchinson
thank you
thank you for doing your patriotic duty
and helping the american people
get a complete understanding of january
6
and its causes
thank you for your courage in testifying
here today
you have the gratitude of this committee
and your country
i know it wasn't easy to sit here today
and answer these questions
but after hearing your testimony in
all this candor and detail
i want to speak directly to the handful
of witnesses
who have been outliers in our
investigation
the small number who have defied us
outright
those whose memories have failed them
again
and again
on the most important details
and to those who fear donald trump and
his enablers
because of this courageous woman and
others like her
your attempt to hide the truth from the
american people will fail
and to that group of witnesses
if you've heard this testimony today
and suddenly you remember things you
couldn't previously recall
or there are some details you'd like to
clarify
or you discovered some
courage you had hidden away somewhere
our doors remain open
the select committee will reconvene in
the weeks ahead
as we continue to lay out our findings
to the american people
the chair requests those in the hearing
room to remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
the witness and members from the room
without objection
the committed stands are joined
and there you have it the adjournment of
the committee
with bombshell testimony
from the aid of the former white house
chief of staff mark meadows
cassidy hutchinson
as
chairman benny thompson described it
they're doing her patriotic duty today
i want to bring in someone who
understands donald trump better than
most
because he's been close to
the former president united states he
was his former personal attorney
michael cohen is joining us now
uh michael i want to get your take on
some of the testimony today uh as we
watch
to see
cassidy hutchinson here
um being taking photos as she's leaving
what was some of your take on the
testimony today michael
like everybody else's you're just
sitting there shaking your head uh tony
and saying wow i mean um
from the
throwing of the food against the wall in
the white house
all the way to the attacking of his uh
secret service agent in the beast
you know to the fact that each and every
one of b it appears to me that each and
every one of these gop members knew
exactly what was going to happen in
advance of january 6th insurrection and
yet
they all said nothing they all
they all did absolutely nothing and i
hope that the people that are watching
this program on midas touch live i hope
that they remember this the testimony of
an insider like i was when i testified
in congress an insider who's telling you
that donald trump is a clear and present
danger to the united states of america
but i want to make one more point it's
not just donald it's all of these
enablers i mean you may recall when mark
meadows and jim jordan and matt gates
and a whole slew of others attacked me
the day that i testified before the
house oversight committee and my
response back to them was i know what
you're doing i've been there i know the
playbook you know how i wrote it and i
know that you're going to see the same
headaches that i'm seeing and then it
might me and my family are dealing with
right now and lo and behold two years
plus later another thing that i had said
is coming true and i got to be honest
with you what they did
is
it's it's uh unimaginable i mean there's
just no way to describe or to put into
words the level of
deceit to the american people only
criticism of today's testimony and all
of the testimony by all of these folks
why didn't they come out sooner because
if cassidy's and god bless her and i
really hope she stays safe because it's
great they love to get you up there they
turn around they tell you what you've
done is patriotic to the country but
nobody nobody except for a handful of us
know the danger that donald trump poses
to you and your family once you leave
those halls so i want her to remain safe
but at the end of the day you have to
turn around and you have to get out
there you gotta vote
all of these animals out of office
because look what they wanted to do is
what i warned the country also two years
ago as the first person to do it there
will never be a peaceful transfer of
power if donald trump loses the 2020
election
well let me ask you because you you talk
about her safety and we even um
we seen statements from witnesses like
hey be loyal be loyal and everything
will be fine nothing you know nothing
will happen to you um this seems to be a
pattern with the trump world and trump
himself is that these thin belts threats
it it almost seems like witness
tampering um
you know adam
what do you mean tony it almost seems
like it is witness tampering it's
witness tampering and obstruction of
justice just look it up in wikipedia and
you'll see exactly the actions that
donald trump and his acolytes do
is witness tampering and obstruction of
justice plain and simple but yet look
we've seen enough testimony from this
hearing we have seen enough information
over the course of the last two plus
years in order to have locked this man
away for a long time but not just him
it's the whole group of them
stunning testimony today exceptionally
important to history but then again it's
just adding another layer to the cake of
the illegalities that donald trump in
his you know and his inner circle are
responsible for over many many years
what did you make of the
um temper tantrum but particularly the
one
in the vehicle in the beast that they
described where he he physically put his
hands on the wheel and physically put
his hands on someone i find it you know
kind of
i guess hilarious we watched rudy
giuliani get padded on the back and
somehow he was you know suplexed onto
the ground but here we have the
president united states he's so pissed
off that they won't allow him to go to
the capitol to crown be crowned king or
whatever he thought was going to happen
so upset that he was he was willing to
physically put his hands on the person
who was going to protect him what do you
make of that that image yeah look i've
seen donald trump throw tempeh tantrums
on a handful of occasions in my book
disloyal i actually uh cite one incident
which was against don jr when don jr
said the wrong thing uh while we were at
the wwe raw uh where there was a schtick
going on with him and vince mcmahon for
the purchase and then the sell back of
the wwe to him uh don said the wrong
thing it was a pretty innocuous
statement uh
that
do you ever get nervous going out in
front of big crowds like this in essence
what don was trying to do is to tell his
dad it's a huge crowd because even back
then
size matters for trump and obviously not
according to stormy daniels but size
matters um you know in trump land and
that set him off to the point you know
that he went ballistic don jr got thrown
out of the room i ended up leaving to go
talk to him you know because he was
obviously upset over his father's
reaction but i've seen other events
where trump starts slamming his hand you
know on the desk and so and you would
think you know that he broke his hand
that's how hard that he hit it but you
know who these actions remind me a lot
of is like the actions of like kim
jong-un um you know when
he behaves in a way which is so
narcissistic and dictatorial that
i'm not shocked at anything that came
out of cassidy's mouth today i'm just
disappointed that this information
didn't find its way to the american
people months and months and months ago
especially during the second impeachment
so what do you make of
maybe the movement from here on out now
that we had this out in the space i mean
it seems like there's a lot of people
who have criminal liability now just
from the testimony that was uh spoken
today by cassidy one person in
particular would be her former boss mark
meadows um man
you have chipoloni on top of that you
have you know potentially jared on top
of that you also have um you have jim
jordan you can also have thrown into
this whole mix uh you know a handful of
other individuals that were all involved
uh especially the group roger stone
you know who took the fifth general
flynn i mean all of these folks that
took place
that got together at the january 5th
hotel meeting i mean i think each and
every one of them knew well in advance
something that i've been talking about
for a long time now every single one of
them knew in advance what was going to
happen because donald told them to do it
i've stated this a million times and
it's worth repeating nothing went on in
the white house without donald trump
knowing about it firsthand nothing ever
went on at the trump organization
without donald trump knowing about it
firsthand from the acquisition of real
estate to the purchasing of paper clips
the man was involved in every single
aspect of both the company and the white
house which he ran exactly the same way
did he pick the ketchup that he would
throw against the wall i'm just i'm
trying to figure out exactly how many
details because that was one of the
images that she gave us is that
she came in and this wasn't the first
time she had had witnessed this where he
had thrown his plate against the wall
because he was so mad and i guess the
ketchup you know thing kind of stands
out it's it's kind of a funny point but
i think the point she was trying to make
in her testimony is that he he really
was like this all the time when he
didn't get his way and it was obvious
the day of january 6 that he wasn't
getting his way mike pence wasn't doing
what he told him to do um people weren't
escorting him to the capitol like he
told them to do
they just weren't doing what he wanted
for the for them to make him king
and ultimately that's maybe why the
ketchup ended up on the wall i guess
that's kind of a funny side point but
really into all the seriousness here
how dangerous how dangerously close were
we to donald trump um
bullying these people into doing what he
wanted to do and tearing down our
democracy how well you have to give them
you have to give them a lot of credit
for standing up it is not easy and i've
also said this uh ad nauseam it is not
easy standing up to donald trump uh the
guy is beyond vindictive the man knows
no shame he has no empathy so he will go
to any length out there in order to get
what it is that he wants including
putting his own life and everybody
else's life in jeopardy by grabbing a
hold of a steering wheel while the beast
which is like a 20 000 pound vehicle i
mean the doors i don't know if you've
ever been in the beast or felt the beast
i've closed the doors um you know to the
beast um you know with myself when i was
allowed to sit inside of it um those
doors weigh like 10 000 pounds i mean
it's crazy and he grabbed the wheel of
the beast while it's in motion simply
because the
baby in chief wasn't getting what he
wanted he didn't get a chance to go
march with people he allowed weapons to
be you know brought close you know to uh
you know to the to the rally that he was
speaking he put everyone's life in
jeopardy but here's the thing that
cassidy stated and it's true
his only thought was that they will not
hurt me these are my people so he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if it was your life
in jeopardy or anybody else maybe a
journalist from cnn or msnbc or abc nbc
cbs it didn't make a difference to him
who was there who can get hurt knowing
that they wouldn't hurt him he wanted to
be there he actually wanted to walk them
through the capital that's how i see you
know knowing him as well as i do that's
what he wanted to do to lead the charge
hoping that that would intimidate mike
pence to call the whole thing off then
he would end up taking over and
remaining as president whether it was
for an extra day or an extra year or
whatever it might be the man is a
narcissistic sociopath who has
autocratic tendencies and
somehow or another he managed to
bamboozle his way you know into the
white house and become the worst version
of himself ever imaginable i never
thought that this would be the way that
i remember you know the legacy of donald
trump ever
well but speaking of legacy of donald
trump he's adding to the legacy this
afternoon by i know i guess you call it
truthing i i'm not really sure um i want
to bring those up real quick here um he
he
says he hardly knows who this person
cassie hussein is that's a very typical
um he didn't know who i was either
remember that right absolutely his
second one here from just uh you know 20
minutes after he says never complained
about crowd size it was massive um i
mean you know we can go back and read
these statements it's full of a bunch of
gibberish to be quite honest just
because he's he's [ __ ] lying here he
can't help himself but to lie it's
really ironic that this is truth i think
we have some more uh clips here uh here
here is another from 20 minutes later
her fake story that i tried to grab the
steering wheel of the white house
limousine in order to steer into the
capitol building is sick and fraudulent
very vigilant is the wrong word by the
way okay right well
you know when he's saying these things i
believe he's saying yes i did these i
have to say i didn't do these because i
did do these things um by making these
statements he says very much like the
unselect committee itself wouldn't even
have been possible to do such a
ridiculous thing her story of me
throwing food
is also false and why would she i don't
know why he can't believe she there have
to clean it up i hardly knew who she was
okay first of all you may remember in
her testimony she didn't have to clean
it up she felt bad for the man uh that
was
um that was cleaning up and she lent a
hand that's generally what people do
right when you have empathy for another
person but then again he finishes it by
stating that he hardly knew who she was
that's the three d's of donald trump
right it's distance yourself denigrate
and then deflect to something else then
he goes on to talk about in the in the
last true social one that she changed
lawyers at the last time that happened
to me as well i was being bombarded by a
guy named costello who was involved with
giuliani who wanted to be part of the
defense team when
when i was um undergoing after the fbi
raid and uh the
alleged
uh you know
investigation into me and all that other
nonsense they wanted to put this guy
costello in they want their people in
the game in that way they could report
back so that you can be directed to stay
on message it's exactly how the mob
works the don tells you right no pun
intended here the don tells you use this
guy he's he's he's one of us he's part
of the family right he'll keep you safe
put your arms around them until you have
to shoot them that's what donald is all
about right denigrate
distance and then deflect on to
something else it's the 3ds and he does
the same thing every time it's about
time that press and and you know um
folks who are supporters of trump start
to see this and rest assured
i guarantee if i go onto my cell phone
right now i've already received an email
from donald trump's uh what do you call
his campaign finance you know
organization hey you know just got
smashed and attacked by the unselect
committee send fifteen 15
right because we have to fight this i
guarantee you this
[ __ ] grifter in chief is going to do
everything in his power to suck even
more money out of this i mean it's funny
this is bothering him a lot it'll bother
him a lot worse if he doesn't make money
off of it but this is really bothering
him the fact that you have all of these
people coming together and corroborating
what we already know we've already read
the emails the text messages and so on
and the recordings we've already heard
seen and read these things so we knew
exactly what cassidy was going to be
responding to it was just nice to have
it coming first person from somebody
like myself who was a fly in the wall
during a certain period of time
michael i really appreciate you joining
us um i'm going to go to the panel here
but i i know your insight is always
valuable do you want to stick around for
the panel or do you have to or you have
to jump i'll stick around for you just
take a minute okay yeah that sounds
great that sounds great you know you
have look you have a lot of people that
are on right now i know asking a million
and one questions here and um
there is a lot there is a lot of people
um let me bring in some of our panel
here um i thought we were gonna have
some footage of interviews afterwards
but we're not going to have um that
going on i think i believe because
um they're cutting the footage i don't
think that they're letting the select
committee give interviews uh after the
fact here um and the and the reason why
is maybe because of security i think
they have some security concerns
um i think i have everybody here yes i
do um jessica you had something that you
wanted to say personally about uh
trump and and maybe being pressured i
know
you have experience with this maybe you
give us insight into this
yeah i just wanted to to point out i
tweeted about this that that how i mean
if you're a woman who's lived this this
gas lighting this playbook in that first
tweet where he said um i've heard very
negative things about cassidy hutchinson
she's bad news
um i know we all know this is complete
[ __ ] and gaslighting but to his
supporters this is the narrative that
goes out and i experienced this first
hand i mean i had an episode where i was
literally running an errand for stephen
miller one night going out picking
waiting for hours at a kinkos to pick up
the ken starr report that he so he could
have it the next day for a debate and
that night an insane insane rumor went
around trump tower that i have learned
about through the discovery in my
lawsuit where it was um being told that
i was rummaging through people's offices
through kellyanne conway's office
through dave possey's office i was
called by my former boss this [ __ ] is
out of control what's her malfunction
um you know
basically bad news this woman is bad
news it is such a misogynist sick
card to play on women so um you know i'm
just i i dealt with this in in silence
and privacy in enormous she's
she has kind of a separate situation to
deal with because she is very public and
i hope that publicity gets her the
protection that she needs and i think it
will i really pray and hope that it does
i was in a very different scenario where
i couldn't say anything and i had to
deal with all of these lies and this
this an unbelievable pressure and
slander in silence um and so i you know
i empathize with her on that and and she
is extraordinarily brave again just i
want to emphasize what we started this
conversation off with that here is a
woman who is it it's a woman telling the
truth it's a woman dropping the bombs
it's a woman confronting the evil and
it's going to be women that bring this
mother figure down finally hold him
accountable for once and for all and
demand that that we move forward without
this sickness and poison in in the
american fabric anymore
uh karen i want to go to you too but i
want to pull up why you're while you're
talking here because i want to go to the
former prosecutor um because i i think i
think it it just seems to be that um
maybe the
assumption that jessica was making at
the break that maybe something is coming
from doj that that not just that
speculation that possibly this is the
reason why they wanted to get this out
in the open as fast as they possibly
could um do you think you think we'll
see people like mark meadows and
handcuffs by the end of the week i you
know i just i think the world wants to
know
i you gotta unmute there
sorry thank you
um it seems to me
the two things that that struck me about
uh about this testimony today was i
believe that the select committee is
working close with the department of
justice um because i they don't want to
do anything to disrupt the investigation
in any way or create any kind of issue
or situation where
witnesses are testifying that they they
might not want to testify publicly
so i think that this must be coordinated
and i do believe something is coming out
with mark meadows you know a lot of um
a lot of what ms hutchinson talked about
was uh was all of what mr meadows was
doing and more importantly not doing and
you know when she talked about the three
camps you know the ivanka was in the
camp of you know stop them make them
stop there was the neutral camp and then
there was the meadows
and and trump camp and i i think it's
pretty clear
that she is um
is going to be a critical witness
against mark meadows and that the
department of justice it seems to me
that that's sort of the next step in
this investigation and prosecution
they're getting closer and i think that
potentially is why she testified now so
that the american people would
understand and know exactly what his
culpability was
what um a little bit of giuliani and his
and donald trump um and i think i do
think it's a coordinated effort to
um to let people know kind of what the
evidence is what the testimony is the
other thing i thought was sort of
interesting
in addition to the things that everyone
else already talked about and uh you
know just about the violence and the the
being out of control and being emotional
and i agree with michael that it sounds
very much like a
you know a mafia playbook you know the
way he he runs things but the thing that
i thought was was quite um interesting
was the two were the two closing
statements by um
representative uh thompson and cheney
where they both basically
was talking about kind of witness
tampering and witness threats
and so i i really felt like they were
sending a message that
you know we know your playbook we know
that you call people up and
and say things like you know
like you know we know you're a team
player or you'll be taken care of and
that that those are being viewed as
threats
and
uh and that they're not going to take
that lightly and if you do threaten
witnesses before they come here we will
um take that very seriously i don't
think it's a coincidence that they did
that with her testimony uh today i think
they were clearly sending a message that
that's what they're doing
and that they're on to them and that
they better [ __ ] stop because it's
outrageous and so i do think it's those
two things
um
that this hearing kind of you know why
it was today and why it was an emergency
i agree with all of the things you guys
you you were saying earlier tony that um
you think it's about threats i think
that was very clear with those closing
statements that that's what it's about
but i do think that the
the circle is closing in on the inner
circle getting closer to the white house
and i think today was was mostly about
meadows and reconstructing
uh
the day the january 6 kind of um what
trump was doing and where he was i i
wouldn't be surprised if
if they're getting closer to finally
prosecuting him
because karen's spot on on that with the
witness statement and um you know one of
the things that i've also you know
frequently stated is the way that they
operate is they put the lawyer in with
you but i just want to go through the
witness statement if i may uh you know
that was put out by uh congresswoman
cheney when they
what they said to me is as long as i
continue to be a team player they know
that i'm on the team i'm doing the right
thing i'm protecting who i need to
protect you know i'll continue to stay
in good graces in trump world and they
have reminded me a couple of times that
trump does read transcripts and just to
keep that in mind as i proceed through
my depositions and interviews with the
committee it's almost exactly the same
as the text messages emails things that
were sent to me by guys like costello
and and giuliani and a couple of
messages that would come in from other
people that were still in trump world as
i was testifying um before the various
different committees at the beginning of
the
investigations um you know like like i
said boy you know congresswoman cheney
is really
um she's she's really just a beast i
mean the way she's handling these
proceedings i mean she
in and of herself really deserves some
type of a congressional award uh for
doing what she's doing and remember she
too put her own career on the line here
so you know that has to be noted
especially the fact that she's a
republican
david did you have something that you
wanted to add i i did and and and
michael uh and and jessica both of you
have been on the inside of this uh and
and indeed michael you just made the
point that i i was
i i was remembering what happened uh
when uh you uh went through
uh
this initial period and were receiving
those messages i think i think some of
them were even taped uh messages to you
let me ask you something
if if you experienced this both of you
uh saw how this playbook went out what's
going on right now
uh now that this has happened
uh we see it on truth social we know
he's not writing a lot of it because
it's spelled properly
so what is going on what is their
playbook now that
uh
these people are cooperating what in
your view for from the inside both of
you having seen it what's he gonna do
now this must be killing him
yeah there's no doubt that he's really
angry right now but here's the donald
trump playbook
something roy cohn the famous attorney
once taught him when he was a kid
deny deny deny all right you know no
fingerprints for me considering i have
no email you're not seeing any
handwritten notes like you're seeing
from meadows it wasn't me it's somebody
else and that's why i think that the
next group of people that you're going
to start seeing fbi agents showing up on
giuliani meadows
chipoloni you're gonna start seeing a
whole slew of these folks now um
getting patted down by fbi agents it's
really bad for all of them because
remember donald trump has no loyalty we
always used to say in the office he's
like first avenue right one way and he
doesn't give a rat's ass about any of
these folks and as long as he can escape
responsibility something he's done his
entire life he will use whatever levers
of power that he still has and he will
make sure that each and every one of
these folks ends up under the bus well
in advance of him are you betting that
he will escape guarantee i don't believe
that he is going to be um indicted for
any of this i i don't but i believe that
everyone else around him will i do
believe charges may be brought but i
think it's going to be very difficult
when the man once again you're not going
to find anything from donald that turns
around and says handwritten documents
emails text messages he doesn't do these
things he was taught as a kid no
fingerprints on anything and he's
managed to escape liability his whole
entire life
using that you know using that um game
plan
i want to say right there yeah
yeah i'm going to take michael to task
on that
let's let's just um let's change the
expectations michael that we've had for
his whole life
let's let's bring justice to bear on
this situation donald trump is going to
be indicted because donald trump needs
to be indicted his fingerprints are all
over the television screens and twitter
and everything else they have been for a
year and a half for god's sakes with the
american people know and the justice
department knows i know
i know you and i michael have been
through hell you've been through much
more than i have you're you've been in
prison but but but don't let that don't
let that taint your faith in the justice
system working now this this hearing it
is late
too much time has passed too much damage
has been done but now is the moment when
these these unfathomable bombshells one
after another i heard someone tweet that
this is like after the second bombshell
it just put you know john dean is like
you know way way in the
doesn't even compare to the bombshells
of today's testimony we we cannot move
past this as as a society without donald
trump being charged and we will demand
it and it will happen so let's raise the
expectations and and expect
finally the right thing to happen
the question that david asked when he
started off this question to me and
michael was what happens next yes donald
trump will continue to gaslight his cult
they will continue to be mobilized to
the point of terrorism by him you know
what stops that for once and for all a
criminal indictment putting donald trump
behind bars a man in prison does not
have the same effect on a cult following
than a free man living on a golf course
so that's what happens next tweet a
little more on your untruth unsocial and
then face face the fire that you've been
avoiding your whole life because it's
coming trump so jessica let me then
respond back to you for a quick second
because i like you have wanted to see
donald indicted incarcerated for his
crimes now i've been very clear and i've
said it on television also many many
times i don't want to see donald trump
or anybody indicted incarcerated um
because i despise them i dislike them i
disagree fundamentally with everything
that they stand for i want to see them
indicted and incarcerated for for crimes
that can be proven now remember one of
the big problems that we have here is
you are still talking about a former
president of the united states and the
system as i have unfortunately learned
is not designed in order to deal with
somebody like donald trump rest assured
i like you and virtually everybody
that's probably watching this i want to
see him indicted all right i want to see
i wanted to see alvin bragg do what he
was supposed to do after i gave 14
different um you know uh meetings with
them over you know a two and a half year
period um i wanted to see indictments
coming out of the d.a no different than
i was happy to see stuff coming out of
georgia and i was happy to see these
hearings moving forward nevertheless
this is still america i don't have a lot
of faith in the department of justice
simply because i went through it and i
understand so much better now than i've
ever understood it before that the
department of justice is designed to
protect the entire institution not an
individual because there's so much
corruption that's going on there and
specifically with this gop they all need
to be indicted only difference they
don't have the um the power that the
president had remember you know this guy
also was given four years of national
security information right at these
briefings
very difficult to put somebody with that
information in prison because donald
trump would sell that information for a
bag of freaking m m's and michael in
fairness you dealt with a different doj
this is a doj now not under bill barr
but under merrick garland
and we're seeing these things happening
in real time we're seeing what happened
to eastman we're seeing what's happening
now
with the doj that is determined
apparently to pursue the facts where
they lead which is what he pledged to do
and this public hearing is pushing them
in that direction so i agree with you
when you were dealing with the doj it
was a very different you know circle the
wagons no collusion no obstruction we
heard that from bill barr for a month
before the report was released
so i i think jessica has a point i think
we may have finally reached a place
where with this happening in public
this is he was taught from birth not to
do emails not to leave notes to burn
everything but he's doing it in plain
sight
so
david do you remember you ever hear the
old you ever hear the expression david
from your mouth to god's ears
yes all right
from your mouth to god's ears i'm just
let me just say i'm less uh i'm i'm more
skeptical than than you are about trump
i believe he will be indicted there's no
doubt in my mind for for one of the many
alleged illegalities that he has been
involved with i just believe that you
know um actually finding him guilty will
be much more difficult than people
believe
so so let me let me uh because i
actually agree with all of you that
um because i think it's it's very
difficult um
right exactly
how much respect i have for michael and
his experience and what he's done and i
do not question his his personal lived
experience and i want i just wanted to
bring full circle on one thing that
michael said he said i don't want to do
this for because i'm you know out of
vindication or you know retribution and
i think that's really important i mean
we've got a panel here of you know three
seven people who really really want to
see donald trump indicted but that's not
what this is about this justice is not a
zero-sum game this is even if donald
trump is indicted and you know god
willing actually put in a penitentiary
it will be the biggest gift that this
man has ever given because he will have
to face the truth something that he's
never lived he has lived a lie his whole
life so it's actually a blessing to
everyone including donald trump all
right well so so i want to say that i
think it is difficult um the the
indictment seems to be easy the trial
the process will be a long process um
through the court and through a trial
system
and maybe even a jury selection could be
very difficult and i'm gonna go to karen
here because she she she has a little
more expertise than most of us on this
panel
about this
but i i am very very very
concerned and i want to
give people the idea that
we have never put a former president of
the united states in a penitentiary we
have never incarcerated
one so we don't know what that is we
don't know what that means we don't know
what a federal judge would do because
karen
am i correct in saying that a federal
judge would actually dictate it within
if he is indicted if he's convicted if a
jury finds him guilty of of charges
a judge gets to decide his fate in that
moment um tell us a little bit about
that because i think
rather he's indicted and he's convicted
and the jury finds him guilty i think
the american people
that will give them some kind of you
know
glad feeling but having a former
president locked up we don't know what
that looks like and a federal judge has
a lot to do with that decision how do
you see
if donald trump were to
face indictment and be
found guilty
would he serve time you think
so don't forget he could be prosecuted
either in state court or federal court
as michael pointed out alvin bragg the
manhattan d.a had a pending case or had
a case an investigation against him uh
that um they did not bring and um still
people are still hoping that he will but
there's also investigation in georgia
you know when he said you know find the
votes find the 12 000 votes so it could
be state court it could be federal court
as you said it's very clear that the
department of justice is investigating
him
and
then if he were to be prosecuted he
would be arrested he'd be brought before
a judge and a judge would decide whether
or not he during the pendency of his
case whether he would be incarcerated
pre-trial
whether he's a flight risk or a risk um
you know a danger to society and those
are the the um balancing sort of that
you know that that they would they would
do whether he could have house arrest or
an ankle monitor i mean there's very
different ways a federal judge could
decide what to do pre-trial with him
he would then be prosecuted like anybody
else and he would have to be indicted he
um would be prosecuted he would then go
to trial and um he'd probably have a
jury trial i i'm almost 100 sure it
would be a jury trial um and then
you know it would they would present
evidence it would have to be
admissible evidence and interestingly
these hearings which have been
phenomenal uh
some of some of what they present is
hearsay and so some of what they have
presented would require a live testimony
um and not just the hearsay that they
have so
i'm sure the federal prosecutors are
watching these hearings to see
what evidence would be admissible
evidence um and then you know it goes to
a jury and a jury decides and um
of course the sentence is is up to the
judge um if he is convicted and uh yes
he could go to prison for sure for all
of these crimes that's just sort of the
process you're right that that there's
no sitting united states president who's
ever been prosecuted um we have i'm sure
prosecuted other uh you know we like to
to
be the world's um police and so
i'm sure there have been former other
kind of presidents in other countries
that we have prosecuted for various
corruption um
you know and um
but yeah but we've never
but we've never prosecuted a president a
former president of the united states um
in the criminal justice system as as we
know nixon was pardoned um kind of right
away so he never faced you know he was
the closest we got he was he he never
faced um
prosecution so you know we'll see
we will see i think it's happening i
think he's going to be
uh i think the cuffs are going to go on
him i don't know if it's state or
federal but i think someone's going to
do it and then i think others are going
to do it i think it's just going to take
someone to go first and as soon as
somebody goes first i think
yeah i i actually don't get together
who we love that here to michael's point
about him selling information
there's a way to lock somebody up where
they have no contact and i think that
was true with noriega no contact
whatsoever with the outside world
i'll tell you that
whether he gets locked up or not he is
absolutely terrified this afternoon um
before before i go to some of these uh
truths or whatever the hell they're
called that he's putting out here on on
his uh his fraudulent social media site
tooth central as he calls it at his
rallies i want to um give everybody the
chance to go over to
store.minustouch.com get your convict or
convict 45 the union made in the usa
enamel pen just used the i like convict
by the way
i just wanted to bring up one one thing
i know this is going to seem almost
comical though it's obviously not but as
the former president he is entitled to
secret service protection for the rest
of his life could you imagine if in fact
he does get locked up i wonder if the
secret service agents have to go with
them wouldn't that be something what
what a way to pull a detail on that
well and that's why i i say i don't know
what it looks like i don't know what a
feminist it doesn't look like it doesn't
look like what happened with noriega and
miami by the way in in all fairness
noriega had a cadre of people he had his
own specific block and he had people
working for him while he was there it's
a it's a very famous story uh but
yes i totally agree um it's never
happened i agree with karen 100 it's
never happened in the united states and
i think
merrick garland fears that it would be
setting a precedent for other presidents
then or other um parties to go after
members of the competing party in the
future right
now
merrick garland is really truly
concerned about
uh texas paul i know you've been waiting
patiently because i know he's got a ton
of notes here i know he does but i i
want to bring you up but i want to go to
because i know these things really piss
you off um but here is here's some more
of these these truce i guess that he's
putting out uh he misspelled cheney here
uh cheney conveniently left out the
snippet in my speech to quote go
peacefully and patriotically of course
the capitalization doesn't make much
sense here um and isn't she disgraceful
and he seems really terrified of darth
vader junior excuse me liz cheney as i
refer to a dirtbag junior but he also
tweet our truce out here whatever again
whatever the hell it's called um he puts
out in the statement here he says there
is no cross-examination of this
so-called witness this is a kangaroo
court i
you know i always have said that it was
a cheeto dust kangaroo coup so maybe it
is appropriate that donald trump uh in
on his fraudulent social refers to this
as a kangaroo court and but we must not
forget that the person who questioned
the witness almost the entire time is a
republican
not a democrat a republican and most
democrats wouldn't vote for her if their
if if she was the last politician on
earth this is not some kind of liberal
democrat uh
uh
radical it's liz cheney that was
questioning her the entire time so what
do you make of his statements versus the
testimony today obviously he's a whiny
little [ __ ] but what do you make of it
texas paul give us give the midas mighty
the the texas fall version here
he's [ __ ] terrified
he's [ __ ] terrified this is not a
court
this is a political exercise and he
knows he lost
that's exactly what this is is crowd
control
they have laid it out from the beginning
donald trump in the fir before the
election tried to use dejoy and local
states like ken paxton here
said said it out loud if it wasn't for
me donald trump would have lost texas
that was before the election they laid
out that he was told by everyone around
him that he lost
he went into steel mode he tried to use
the same legislatures that he tried to
steal the election with to
try to steal it again i mean he after
the fact
then he tried to use the doj then he
tried to use the military when all of it
failed he tried to use the proud wars
and the oath keepers to to to try to
hold on to power it all failed he is
[ __ ]
terrified and he is going to burn
there is no way he walks away from this
i don't care what anybody says that's
exactly what this is is this is a
political exercise to prepare the nation
for the fact
that
we are going to start seeing
people all around donald trump and karen
knows how it works you don't start
convicting at the top you flip them one
after the other after the other after
the other after the other
today's testimony was to give you the
clearest shittiest picture possible of
donald trump
so that people don't riot
so that people don't
you know there's no valid claim that
he's innocent
this this is all a political exercise to
free merrick garland up to do exactly
what he has already planned to do they
are coordinating they are coordinating
this is the public
face of it
but donald trump is [ __ ] for all
eternity there's no way he walks away
from this there's too much out there too
many people
you know you're right his fingerprints
aren't on it but when you have 15 people
around you saying he did it
he told me to [ __ ] do it
i guarantee you there's not a jury in
this country that is going to let donald
trump walk away unless they end up with
some maga [ __ ] on there some
cult member
this is over that's exactly what this is
and
i will give you this hat tony if i am
wrong
i'm going to hold him
i may be holding him to that hat because
i happen to like it all right walking
around the streets of manhattan you know
especially now that we have the open gun
law um
look i'm with you on everything that you
say except for one thing i was there
with the creation of this playbook and
i'm telling you the fact that his
fingerprints are not on anything and you
could have a hundred people it's still
it's still hearsay show me the
documentary evidence to which that we
could corroborate other than other
people it's a very tough case for a
prosecutor and look i want him to be
held accountable for something i mean
for god's sakes i went to prison
because i paid a porn star who pulled
the president's mushroom pecker end of
story that's the only legitimate charge
despite i had to plead guilty to others
i don't know if i if you read this or
i've told it to you they threatened to
indict my wife and i had 48 hours from
start to finish of my case so and i have
a book that's going to come out about
this relatively soon called the
department of injustice that's why i'm
so um down on them they need a massive
overhaul and i hate to say it i don't
believe merrick garland has the cojones
to do it actually i'm pretty certain
because this is a big moment in american
history it's a huge moment all right i
do believe he gets this brilliant woman
right here ask this brilliant woman
right here to my right
point this point this way yeah this way
texas park
no you know what actually the vote you
have
it's the phone you know what
to michael's point okay what somebody
sit and say
i heard him say it i saw him say it and
i guarantee you mark meadows is a [ __ ]
and i know i'm going to catch so much
hell for using that euphemism from the i
know don't stop typing i know
but he is a [ __ ]
he is and he will just argue here say
it's an odd statement offered to prove
the truth of the matter asserted therein
that's the truth
he told me not i heard him say
not some blow you know it you know
i guarantee you that is not hearsay
i think to i think
i think though
put it putting that aside um i've always
said i think that the the best case is
the georgia case and that phone call is
on tape and that's trump's words himself
and when you put that all together in
context with all this other evidence of
what his intent was and what he was
looking for and that he knew that the
election was not stolen from him it
wasn't a big you know fraud
etc etc and that's on tape that's his
own words that's why i think that's the
case that needs to be brought because
you you know you you can prove that he
knew that he was told over and over and
over and over again that that and both
by judges in court and by his lawyers
and
by everybody else and then he still
calls up and makes that recording on
tape i think that's absolutely the um
the case that needs to be brought and
why i've always said that's the case um
that needs to happen plus i i agree
there is a question with merrick garland
about setting precedent and about
you know worrying about the legitimacy
of you know any any sort of prosecution
by someone who is appointed by a
democrat you know and and and worrying
about the future you know i do think
there's a little reticence there um but
i that's why i think georgia needs to do
it and
hopefully alvin bragg will still do it
but i do think i do think merrick
garland's gonna do it um and i do and i
think that if enough people i think
michael has a point he doesn't have
fingerprints anywhere but i think if
enough people come forward and have
there's power in numbers i think that's
going to be enough um even if there are
no recordings and no papers and
pardons so so let me say that you
prosecutors are lone rangers none of you
are you know damn well y'all work
together y'all y'all know damn well you
work together they're going to bury him
under so many freaking prosecutions he's
going to have he is going to have
so many people coming to him
i agree if someone has to go first
someone has to go first if somebody goes
first i think the others are gonna fall
yeah the one that should have gone first
would have been alvin bragg despite the
fact that he allowed
your limitations to run on that case and
i'll tell you why i want everybody to
remember
who's the most famous gangster out there
that they couldn't prosecute for the
murders and all the other stuff but they
got him on the table
and they got on taxes all right they had
him on the taxes they have him who's
that last week
i know oh is that you texas
all right i know for a fact the
documents because i spent so much time
with them why they allowed this to walk
away who cares what's the reason that
the man is behind bars who cares which
is the illegal actions taken by donald
that puts him away and out of our lives
no one so they should have gone with the
low hanging fruit instead
finding you know one out of 12 jurors
who's going to be a trump sycophant
acolyte follower is going to be real
difficult right and that one person can
hold up the entire the entire thing
cause mistrials and so on this is not an
easy case and um they should have gone
after the low-hanging fruit put the
guy's ass away you know makes no
difference to me if it's the sedition
argument whether it's uh trying to
attempt a coup or tax evasion makes no
difference at all
yeah and i mean
really quick read mark pomerantz's
resignation letter in the you know he
was the prosecutor under alvin bragg
read his resignation letter he says
there is no perfect case but this case
we have enough let's bring it you know
and that is true there is no perfect
case and but but prosecutors do it all
the time every single day and i
completely agree michael that case
should have been brought and
um and alvin who you know i obviously
love the manhattan da's office and think
very highly of it um i think this was
just the wrong call
yeah terrible terrible call but just
going back to merrick garland and what
um
the presumed pressure that he's under to
set a precedent of charging a a former
president and the notion that that might
be a bad precedent i think is just
ludicrous first of all donald trump set
his own ludicrous precedent of being
president in the first place so we have
to counter that with the appropriate
action um last week we had that uh kind
of
what i considered to be an article that
really sowed a lot of doubt and concerns
by jonah goldberg i think michael
referenced it last week
about the possible ramifications
political you know framing of a
prosecution of donald trump and then on
friday there was an excellent follow-up
piece by rick hassan and the new york
times that kind of got
you know overrun by the roe news about
why any possible risks of indicting
donald trump are far outweighed by the
need to the absolute need to and we do
have these other cases i have a lot of
faith like karen does in georgia and
fanny willis um but i think
from a federal standpoint i mean we're
talking about a treater a traitor here a
man who committed treason there should
be a federal record for history um in
our country even if prosecution is hard
even if it doesn't result in conviction
that those federal charges from the
department of justice are brought and
going back to the role that we play
because i i don't have enormous faith in
merit garland either i wish that someone
of a you know more
maybe a stronger individual was chosen
for that role i think you and i the
american people just like we flooded the
streets um you know to protest for
george floyd and all these social
justice justice movements way we flooded
the streets to you know protest against
roe versus wade
we we need to show that we are demanding
this i i was outside scotus after the
leaked opinion i said to one of the
organizers i said do you think we could
get this same energy at the department
of justice and she's like yeah i think
so because it's damn well as important
if i mean it's as important there is
nothing more important to our future as
a free people than holding donald trump
accountable so
us out here in society we have a role by
by making our voices heard if it
requires you know michael and i have
talked about this there are risks
involved
getting people to you know
stand and demand protest demand that the
department of justice take action um and
let them know that we will stand for
nothing less so i i want to go to some
more
jesus some more truths gabe has put them
up here for me but before that
social media we're going to talk about
social media here everyone follow the
midas touch youtube channel here um go
ahead and hit the subscribe button like
and share
this this hearing with your family and
friends we're going to be back in july
or any other special type of hearings
that they have that they urgently call
we'll be back with those hearings right
here on the midas media network so be
sure to follow the midas touch youtube
channel and go over and follow the tony
michael's podcast on youtube as well you
can catch on minus touch you can catch
legal af you can catch michael's show
here on the midas touch youtube channel
as well so follow us and also all the
great uh react videos from texas paul um
so don't miss those on the midas touch
youtube channel and do me a favor go
over to the tony michaels podcast and
follow our channel as well i want to
bring up this other here's another he
he's on a tirade here i mean he just
can't stop it's her body language is
that of a total bull artist fantasyland
i i have no idea what he what the hell
that even means um and then he says well
everybody will anybody ever be allowed
to say that the election was rigged or
stolen you keep yammering on about it
you chucklehead um will the unselects
ever discuss that our country is going
to hell because of a fraudulent election
how about analyzing election results
this is all again just complete utter
nonsense um from the former guy himself
gabe what do you make of the you're
you're you're looking at true social
right now i'm i'm listening to the panel
in the in the background i'm following
along i he just keeps posting and i
cannot keep up to make these graphics
but he is he said everything from what
you just said as well as he has some
additional ones where he said a total
phony he said i never said mike pence
deserves it to be hung another made-up
statement by a third-rate social climber
bad handwriting that of a wacko question
mark why didn't they use the 10 000
troops that i offered on january 3rd
there would have been no january 6th so
he's you know he he's he's really ra
he's doing those 3 a.m rage post where
he sits on the [ __ ] and he's just
going at it and right now i just can't
keep up with them but i mean like
looking at this i just
have to agree
uh with everything that people are
saying is like he well i think also in
addition to that he is going to um
he might even say something that he
doesn't mean to say he might admit to
something that you know in his rage he
goes ahead and says just
you know and hands up to someone that
might be investigating him i don't know
but
uh you know it's it really does tell you
we we heard it during the testimony he
tried to grab the wheel he tried to
choke the secret agent he was throwing
food against the wall donald trump is a
child he is having a tantrum and right
now he is kicking and screaming in
mar-a-lago upset because these truths
have come out and now he's trying to use
truth social to truth himself out of the
actual truth
so
it's completely ridiculous i mean we do
again we have a child that was a there
was a president he is completely having
a tantrum and the guy is
he's right you can't you can't write
this
he's terrified liz cheney beat the [ __ ]
out of him politically
she beat the living [ __ ] out of him
politically and he knows it well i'll
tell you i'll tell you uh texas paul
probably knows this uh growing up in in
texas when you when you corner when you
corner a rabid you know possum in a
corner
they are they are very angry and they
start screaming and screeching and
whacking their tail and looking kissing
at you that's exactly what's happening
he is trapped he's in a corner he knows
he knows that he he has nowhere to go
here um so he's lashing out and i know
michael probably knows this better than
anybody
tony let me chime in on this one all
right because there's two donald trumps
here something that everybody has to
understand there's the donald trump who
has moments of clarity where he realizes
that liz cheney who is the daughter of
the former vice president from 2001 to
2009 under george bush all right another
republican is the one that's leading the
charge against him so how is it a
kangaroo court considering the committee
is not even a court as texas paul put it
before but then there's the other donald
trump and this donald trump i hate to
say
takes up most of the brain
whatever's there
in donald trump whereby he's so myopic
if
on truth social people start responding
back to him saying yeah donald you won
yeah donald you're the greatest you're
my fuhrer right um you know they stole
the election from you all of this said
by um you know by uh you know by
the select the select committee and by
all the witnesses is all a lie what he
does then is he focuses laser focuses on
that specific response back and then
that becomes the 100 denominator it's a
very sick and demented um
issue that goes on in between donald's
ears
so we got just a few minutes left i want
to give everyone one last chance to make
a statement about the testimony today
but also uh going forward what they
maybe expect from the committees as you
heard liz cheney and benny thompson at
the end of the hearing kind of give a
projection of what is going to happen in
the hearings that we may uh that we're
going to have in july maybe even sooner
we don't know so i want to go around the
the table here i'll start with uh karen
karen what is your what is your
opinion your last thought of the hearing
today and going forward what these
hearings will bring
so you know it's just interesting that
donald trump's tweet was how come
nobody's testifying about the fraud um
you know about the stolen election but
you know it's very clear that um
everyone who could
give that you know ridiculous
uh opinion has taken the fifth so
you know they they won't
they they can't say it because they know
that's incriminating because there is no
fraud it wasn't stolen
and um and it's not the big lie it's the
big crime
so that's what these hearings in my
opinion have shown is that this is the
big crime and i look forward to seeing
the house of cards uh that is gonna come
down around him uh in the coming weeks
and months with hopefully prosecution
after prosecution after prosecution and
we're all going to look back
at this horrible dark time in our life
and
and and move on the other thing i just
want to say is it's ridic it's so clear
that that cassidy hutchinson got under
his skin he can't stop tweeting like
it's like
i didn't realize you know it's just so
easy to get under this man's skin anyway
those are my final thoughts and thank
you all for um spending the day together
yes good jessica to you
um
yeah let me just bring it back to where
we started today you know we've got a
threat of fascism on two fronts we've
got uh you know fascists trying to run
the right wing and really minority rule
this country and then we've got um
impunity for fascists which is what we
witnessed again today and we're about to
go into um you know
a week or so here independence day um
the foundation of our country you know
separation from a king separation from
um
church having rule over over people and
and the separation of church and state
that's fundamental to our our
founding doctrines our constitution our
freedom
um i just want to remind everyone what
what a pivotal moment in history we are
living through
you and i you've joined us on this
network this network i know i'm so
grateful to be included in is all about
our role what we can do to make sure
that democracy democracy survives and
does not become something that um you
know was a nice idea in history for a
few hundred years so um i just want to
leave everybody with that gravity like i
said in the in the open i'm so grateful
that we had this unexpected hearing
today and oh my god what a hearing it
was it was it was paul to you um give us
your last thoughts there and then i'll
go to michael
thank you michael cohen uh for
everything you've been through and
everything that you brought out into
the public light
you were the start of the downhill slide
for donald trump everything else
everything prior to in
here and all the crime and stuff that
had been going on everything had been
going uphill for him but it'll be a long
haul but you will see some vent you will
see him
in an orange jumpsuit and i am truly
grateful to you my predictions are that
mike flynn's in the ends up committing
suicide uh mark meadows is going to
prison he is a [ __ ]
um and he today he
everything that he kept his mouth shut
for
went out the window today
i mean he's got nothing to offer cassidy
hutchinson put him in jail
there's no deal that he can make after
this other than pointing the finger and
say he may be able to shave sometimes
that's caring about that but
um
rudy giuliani is done
he's done he is going to prison
uh we haven't even gotten to the
violence part yet
we know that there are more hearings
coming where they're going to be
uh uh talking about who coordinated with
the oath keepers who coordinated with
um
the uh proud boys and the fir
1a praetorians that are so tight with
mike flynn
um yeah liz cheney isn't done with
donald trump by a damn site um and
[Music]
he's gonna burn
he is so gonna burn
well i i appreciate
the the words there paul everyone hears
that mind is mighty loves the the way
paul puts things so thanks for joining
us paul michael what's your final
thoughts here on the hearings but but
the hearings going forward as well yeah
so first let me thank texas paul for you
know the kind words so i'll share just a
personal um you know
it's very difficult to put into words
the way the system when it breaks you it
breaks you um you know i do what i do
simply you know um as redemption i know
that you know i'm in part responsible
for the creation of frankenstein's
monster and my hope is that um
we're able to re-cage the beast before
he destroys our democracy i have
children and so on i have you know
nieces nephews i have you know a pretty
large family and they deserve the
democracy that we have
come to know and um
we need to change so much in this
country including the supreme court with
the way that they're running amok right
now but to touch on the hearing so i do
thank you for that uh you know i work on
myself every day i'm you know i i put on
the fun facade but inside you know
people who have done time will tell you
uh you're broken inside and it takes a
long time if ever you know to become
yourself again
um as it relates to the hearings you
know yeah i appreciate all the stuff
that's come out from cassidy um you know
from angle from donahoe from rosen from
all of the witnesses i only wish like
what i did that they would have come out
earlier and maybe none of this would
even be relevant right now
maybe there would have been a way to
overturn trump's decisions to put these
three animals on the supreme court
there's so many things that i wish that
they would have come out earlier with uh
whether it's the first impeachment or
the second that would have been the
right thing to do not post fact uh i
hate when that when that happens and i'm
gonna tell you my reason why
the bigger fear that we have to have is
not donald trump
re-running for president i've told
everybody a long time now he's not
running the guy has more problems than
anybody can even imagine he deserves and
hopefully he will be indicted his
company is going to go under you know
he's not going to be running again and
he also cannot handle being a two-time
loser that's one of the things that is
really keeping him away from the
campaign trail but what we all have to
be concerned about and you know midas
touch is so on top of this all of us
that are on this panel you know
constantly talk about it what happens
with the next one the donald trump 2.0
like iran desantis who's smarter than
trump that's for sure who's probably
better financed with you know um with
the republican party than trump you know
than trump would be um and somebody
who's potentially more devious and
more
disrespectful to the constitution hard
to imagine than donald that's the guy
that we have to be worried about because
donald has now given him a playbook on
how to overthrow the government how to
destroy our democracy and how to
basically you know um tear up our
constitution so we all need to stay
vigilant keep doing what we're doing
thanks to everybody that joined us today
you know obviously take care of midas if
you can stay stay with all of us um you
know keep tuning in because there's so
much more to come
i appreciate all of you being here and
thank you for for joining us and i want
to thank the audience again um i hope
that all of you come back i want to give
a few more shout outs uh here as far as
plugs again follow the midas touch
youtube channel because you will not
only find these hearings there you will
find the midas touch podcast you will
find legal af which karen is a co-host
on wednesdays you will find maya culpa
with michael cohen
you'll find his podcast here as well
you'll find all the videos from texas
paul and also go follow jessica denson
on twitter she is the trump nda killer i
know she's gonna have a lot of stuff
that she's gonna be putting out uh over
the next several months about some of
the cases that she is in at jessica
denson that's
d-e-n-s-o-n-07 jessica denson07 i really
appreciate all of you joining us today
and being with us and staying with us
through the hearing i know this has been
one of the most groundbreaking ones
we've had so far because it has some of
the material in it that we've all been
waiting for we all we all felt like we
knew this or we heard this or they've
been reported on this but now we have
finally come to the moment where we see
this evidence being spoken and being
testified to i want to tell you that i
think these hearings coming up
are because liz cheney and benny
thompson pointed to this at the very end
and he was they were very and they kept
giving these little nuggets did you get
you notice that they give these little
nuggets throughout the hearing and the
upcoming hearings and the upcoming
hearings and the upcoming hearings it's
almost like they have a producer doing
this to to tie you into these these new
episodes and to keep you viewing and to
keep you seeing this evidence so i
implore you i implore you
follow midas touch youtube channel and
go over do me a favor and gabe a favor
and go over and follow our our youtube
channel the tony michaels podcast but
follow both of those
those youtube channels because we are
going to follow these hearings wherever
they may go and we are also going to
have our great panel of guests um i want
to thank david bender is not here and
rachel biddikoffer is not here and i
also want to thank the mizellas brothers
now ben joined us earlier i know brett
and jordy apparently jordy is working on
stealing texas falls cookies
and and
brett was out today but i appreciate
them as well with all the help and i
want everyone to thank gabe sanchez uh
for all the great graphics i know he's
got it he's he's got all these true
socials that he
that he was able to to wrestle up uh
till the very end even though
and we there's probably a thousand more
where that yeah there's definitely more
coming but yeah so thank you very much
to the midas mighty for joining us for
this hearing don't forget to join us for
all the other hearings but also don't
forget to subscribe and click the bell
notification for all the notifications
for all the great videos that will come
out uh thank you panel for joining us
gabe stick around here i want to i want
to ask you about this true show show
real quick thank you thank you all to
our guest thank you very much see you
guys later
uh gabe so let's let's go back real
quick to the yeah that's not even all of
them either i've got a total of 12 but i
i stopped i just stopped making the
graphics after a moment it was just uh
i
they are insane because they're either
just like statements like bad
handwriting that of a wacko like what is
he a total phony
i mean i'm personally a big fan of the i
never said mike pence deserves to be
hung in parentheses another made-up
statement by a third-rate social climber
like i think you know there's a lot of
projection happening here where
he knows he did something wrong clearly
because he did it but and also in his
mind he might not even think that he was
in the wrong like he wasn't in the wrong
to try to choke out a surface a secret
service agent right like he wasn't in
the wrong to fling food across the
the room like
in what world do we live in where the
sitting president is trying to
physically assault the people that are
trying to protect him and he's trying to
make a mess of things in the oval office
again he's just a top like he he's a kid
having a tantrum
wanting to go to [ __ ] bizarro world
disney world
right and the parents like no you know
what we're turning the car around and
we're going home and that is the oval
office and he just doesn't want to
doesn't want to have it doesn't doesn't
want to be
he's convict 45 he's convict 45 or
convict 45 oh yeah i mean you can
convict 45 to become convict 45 there is
a transfer
of the title meaning well well i i want
to give one last shout out for for jordy
he was um wanting this this promo code
justice if you go to
store.minustouch.com use the promo code
justice get 10 percent off i think
there's only just a handful of these
enamel pens left or union made in the
usa whether it's convict 45 or convict
45 go get it now
supplies are very very limited if
they're not out already so run over to
store.mondastush.com use the promo code
justice get 10 off not just a pen but
the the entire store over there at
store.minustouch.com
uh gabe i i'm really looking forward to
this uh these other hearings as vinnie
thompson and
and
liz cheney give these sprinkles of
evidence throughout and what what a what
a fantastic i mean like you said they're
doing a good job you know the through uh
producer kind of guidance to say you
know next week on
the [ __ ] show that is the january 6
you know riot and it's like previously
on the [ __ ] show that was the january 6
riot or just the trump administration in
the final days like either way you want
to look at it they are doing a very good
job of saying next week expect this
last week like i think they're even
doing recaps now where they're doing
snippets uh to kind of give you a
refresher of the you know two to three
hour segment that they that they are in
the hearings to say okay this is what
you missed last week now get ready for
the next reveal the next bombshell and i
mean today was certainly
a you know what we've heard through
rumors or hearsay here in the background
kind of like oh he was doing this or he
was doing that but now we're actually
getting first-hand
uh eyewitness testimony of someone that
is cassidy hutchinson to say yeah
because i think that's the most
important part of the testimony today
was just
just
just the fact that we are that we are
seeing exactly what happened during that
time period right when their siege was
laid on the capitol so again folks do
not forget to subscribe here on youtube
to the midas touch youtube channel also
go over to the tony michaels podcast and
subscribe over there uh you can download
all of the midas touch
podcast on apple spotify google whether
it be the minus touch podcast legal af a
maya culpa kremlin file or if you just
want to see i think they have a new one
they have a new podcast it's called the
mighty they're
seeing this thing every day every day i
know i need to i need to see if we can
figure out exactly what this is so we
can properly promote it here but i i see
this mighty and
apparently it's it's it seems like this
weekend this weekend was like kind of
the premiere of the mighty yeah so go
check that out go check that out on all
the directories um the mighty um and
again follow follow on youtube because
we're gonna have more of these hearings
and i think they're gonna be more and
more groundbreaking as we go along here
so everyone stay tuned uh to the midas
media network thanks for joining us
today on this tuesday june 28th for the
special
urgent day six i guess it would be
called yeah it's an urgent and boy
emergency you know
it did not disappoint it did not
disappoint so thank you and good day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you